what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones video
now that it's a new year I'm sure we
will be getting some winds of winter and
House of the Dragon updates very soon so
make sure you're on the lookout for
those in the meantime I want to go back
to Game of Thrones Season eight as you
all know the ending to Game of Thrones
essentially split the fandom right down
the middle what I want to do in this
video is basically rewrite the entire
final season over a year ago but first
season eight was released I read several
different outlines and plot leaks on my
channel and just like what the final
season some of you did like them and
some of you hated them now when you
consider what Dan and Dave an HBO
actually gave us for their final season
some of those leaks and outlines were
actually far superior than what we got
so what I went ahead and did was
gathered up some of those ideas that I
think make for a much better season I
also sprinkled in some of my own
theories of course so feel free to let
me know what you think down below so
without further ado let's begin now as
you all know the very first episode of
Game of Thrones began at Castle black
with the introduction of the Nights
Watch as well as the White Walkers I
want to do the exact same thing with the
final season I want to begin at Castle
black if you remember season 7 ended
with the night king knocking down the
wall at eastwatch-by-the-sea during the
White Walkers invasion beric Dondarrion
and tormund Giantsbane were able to
escape from that attack so the very
first episode of my final season will
begin what beric in torment arriving at
Castle black to inform everyone of what
happened at Eastwatch immediately after
they were lay the information we will
see several men from the Nights Watch
begin to send out Ravens to inform
everyone about the breakthrough at
eastwatch-by-the-sea right as we are
watching some of these Ravens fly away
from Castle black we will hear the sound
of their horn blow three times
signaling that the army of the Dead are
there at that moment beric Dondarrion
will tell tormund Giantsbane to take a
horse and head south for Winterfell
while barracks stays at Castle black
with Lord Commander IDI and the rest of
the remaining members of the Nights
Watch we can still see all the Ravens
flying with their messages from Castle
black but right is they're almost out of
frame we see the knight king's dragon
burn them all before their messages can
ever make it south to all the other
houses this is when barrack shouts not
all of the dead are coming to Castle
black we can see that the army the dead
have split up only a few hundred whites
are running for Castle black while the
night King is dry
and the rest of his army are heading
south for much bigger targets then the
few hundred White's reach Castle black
and the battle begins you see one of the
many reasons why fans were so
disappointed with season 8 was because
of how the night King story ended
we waited eight seasons for them to get
through the wall and then as soon as
they did they all died during their
first battle at Winterfell well that's
not about to happen in my version of the
events as you can see the final season
opens with an attack from the dead just
like the first season opened with their
introduction this will set the tone for
the entire season winter is here ladies
and gentlemen as well as the night King
and his army of the Dead now let's go to
the next scene another thing that was
very disappointing about the final
season was how bran Starks abilities
were underutilized to say the least I
mean let's be honest bran barely did
anything at all well that's not gonna
happen in my version of the events
either this scene begins with bran stark
sitting in the godswood next to the
weirwood tree we see brains eyes go from
white back to normal he looks over at
the maester and says how long was I gone
the maester says I'm not sure maybe a
few hours brain says he has not seen
anything this time he may have been
thrown out of a vision similar to how he
was thrown out of the Ravens when the
knight Cain noticed he was watching him
brain also says something must have gone
wrong
bran then signals to the maester to help
him back to the courtyard brain says
they are here now we get a big arrival
scene with Jon Snow and Daenerys
Targaryen only in my version this scenes
not going to go on forever and ever
John Daenerys Jorah Tyrion Varys Brienne
the hound and some soldiers arrive
inside the main courtyard of Winterfell
Jorah Mormont immediately notices Sansa
and some of the other northerners are
looking at Daenerys suspiciously they
already let us know how they felt about
Danny last season tyrion lanister looks
around and notices they are already
reinforcing the walls of Winterfell
we then see John and Sansa embrace each
other first
she wants to know how they were able to
get Cersei to agree to send her armies
north which Tyrion then shows a half
smirk and Bowser said sons it looks a
bit surprised as if she doesn't believe
it
then we see John embrace bran it's a
very similar reunion as to the one we
got in the show
John looks very concerned by brands lack
of emotion
Sansa says brand situation is hard to
explain but he has visions now John
looks like he wants to say something but
then he notices Arya and I have to be
honest
the reunion John and Arya had during
season eight was a bit underwhelming for
me which was very disappointing because
it was the one I was looking forward to
the most out of all the stark children I
believe they have the closest
relationship at least in the books they
are both constantly thinking about each
other and I was hoping that would come
across when they finally reunited again
but for whatever reason it just wasn't
as emotional as I was hoping so I would
try to fix that in my version of the
final season now we know that John did
ask her about needle the sword that he
had given her before he left but this
time I would have Arya mentioned
something about just how much the sword
has meant to her as you all know Arya
was willing to kill other characters
over that sword it has also saved her
life on many occasions not to mention
when Arya was training at the house of
black and white she had to get rid of
all her personal belongings to help
enable her to strip away from her former
identity however Needle was the one
thing she could never let go of Arya can
never fully become no.1 because she
could not allow herself to get rid of
the sword and most importantly forget
about her family and life as a stark
needle was not only a gift from John but
it also represented who she was and
where she was from so when we see John
ask Arya about needle I want her to
express this to John in some way
afterwards we can have Sansa and
Daenerys meet for the first time then
Songza can tell Dani Winterfell is yours
your grace we can also see Sam Gilly and
the baby standing across the courtyard
ghost is sitting right next to them
after sons and Dany meet John's gonna
ask Songza where's Littlefinger if you
remember John nearly killed Littlefinger
and the Crips right before he left
Winterfell right as sons and begins to
tell him Arya cuts her off and says I
executed him John is shocked by that
information he knew Littlefinger was a
shady character but he never could have
imagined Arya would be the executioner
John now knows Arya is no longer the
same little sister he grew up with but
before John can even let all the new
information sink in he's then greeted by
Sam and ghost John's gonna bend down and
scratch
right behind the ears while Sam begins
to ask John about the dragon glass from
Dragonstone John will thank him for
sending the information about where the
dragon glass could be located then he's
gonna ensure all of them that there is
more than enough dragon glass to arm
everyone in the north
we then see Tyrion walked over to sons
and asked her how she was able to escape
from King's Landing during Joffrey's
death she says Littlefinger was behind
it Littlefinger has been behind almost
everything he helped her escape from
King's Landing
but he was also the one who helped
martyr Joffrey as well as their aunt
Lysa
Jon Arryn and many many others Jon
wonders how does sons and know all of
this did Littlefinger admit it before
his execution songs is gonna look over
to bran and say I told you he has
visions Jon will look over to bran with
a very surprised look on his face bran
of course is sitting there emotionless
Jon says it's time for all of us to
gather inside the main hall we need to
prepare for the wars to come inside the
main hall Jon can see the look on
everyone's face as Daenerys takes her
seat at the main table the very first
thing he does is remind everyone the
king in the north has bent the knee and
is now serving Daenerys Targaryen yon
Roy stands up and says why haven't you
learned from the mistakes of your uncle
Brandon stark and your grandfather
the Targaryen cannot be trusted John
angrily shouts back at him Daenerys has
came here to save us not only has she
given us as much dragonglass as we could
possibly need but she has also brought
her own armies as well as her dragons
John also says she has already helped me
fight the dead despite how dangerous
that was she even sacrificed one of her
dragons to do so what if you sacrificed
Lord Royce Lord Glover rises to his feet
and says I have not seen any of this for
myself
brain stark says I have seen it they are
telling the truth
Daenerys finally stands and says I'm not
here to slaughter the north I will help
you defeat the night King and then we
will go down south and defeat Cersei
Lannister together Lyanna Mormont says
how was it that you were able to get
Cersei to agree to send her men to help
you knowing she's gonna need those men
later to defeat you Arya Stark follows
this up
we cannot trust Cersei Lannister she
lied to save herself she's not gonna be
sending any of her men to help us
Tyrion Lannister has a concern look when
his face
we then see Sam lo whispered a brand he
says when are you gonna tell Jon the
truth he needs to know bran will say not
right now the tension in the room is
already high Jon Snow will then walk to
the center of the room and say I will
not force anyone to stay here and fight
the dead but if you do stay and we
somehow survive we will go to war for
Daenerys Targaryen because it's obvious
she is here to go to war for us so
whoever is staying here to fight need to
have all of their men get to Winterfell
all of the northern lords and ladies
begin to discuss their options some of
them still seem to be undecided about
what to do this is when bran stark says
we do not have time to argue the dead do
not argue in fact the dead do not speak
they follow one king than I king I knew
many of you may not believe me but I
have seen them I first met the night
King in a vision then he found me in the
far north he has left his mark on me
whatja bran shows the entire room the
night kings mark on his arm Brandon
looks at Daenerys and says he has also
left his mark on your dragon and now
your dragon fights for him this silence
is the entire room
Daenerys appears as if she is about to
cry Brien ends the discussion by saying
the night King and his army are now
south of the wall and they are heading
this way join us in this fight otherwise
everyone you know and love will die now
we go down to King's Landing and I'm
also gonna start this scene off by
having Khyber and revealed a Cersei that
the wall has fallen and the dead are
moving south Cersei will have the same
reaction as she did during season eight
Makai barn is also going to inform her
as something else he will say what he
has been working on his near completion
and that Cersei should come see it for
herself they will walk through the Great
Hall until they reach one of the back
rooms once inside they will go down a
ladder to a cellar that's in complete
darkness except for a faint glow of
green that can be seen for nearly a
hundred yards we can see that there are
hundreds if not thousands of pots of
wildfire stored right underneath the
throne room
Qyburn then says there's
or stashed all over the city he implies
that he has been working nonstop on
producing a unlimited supply of
wildfires since the explosion of the
septa bail or was so successful as
Cersei and Qyburn begin to leave the
cellar we go outside where we see
Euron's fleet arriving in the Blackwater
Bay there are hundreds of ships filled
with gold and Company soldiers we can
see that some of them are already
unloading the cargo there are hundreds
of war horses as well as dozens of
elephants fitted with body armor this is
the golden company we should have seen
during the final season
Harry Strickland and euron greyjoy begin
to have a conversation
Harry Strickland wants to know does the
Narus Targaryen actually have full-grown
dragons he's heard about them yet he has
never seen them for himself
your honor sure sim Daenerys does indeed
have dragons but they have something to
defeat them as they walk to the back of
the silence Euron uncovers one of the
largest ballistas we have ever seen in
the next scene Jaime Lannister meets
what bran at an undisclosed location
before he left King's Landing Jaime sent
word to Bronn to meet him somewhere
along the road to the north
he tells bran he's leaving King's
Landing and Cersei for good he intends
on keeping his word to Jon Snow and
Daenerys Targaryen
and if broad wants to survive the winter
and get what is owed to him he would be
advised to join forces with them as well
bran does not appear to be happy but he
does agree to follow Jaime back in the
north
Jon Snow is down below in the crypts of
Winterfell similar to the scene in
season 8 Daenerys walks down there to be
with John when she stands beside him she
will ask how many family members says he
lost during the recent Wars John will
talk about Ned Catelyn robb and Rickon
he tells her about how Rickon died right
in front of him during the battle for
Winterfell he will tell her about how
Rob was betrayed by some of his own men
John says unfortunately his mistakes led
to his own death this may or may not be
foreshadowing John says Robb was set to
marry a woman but he chose another and
it cost him his life Daenerys then walks
from Ned statue over to Leona's she says
she hasn't noticed any other statues of
a woman down here she must have been
loved by many Jon says she was my aunt
Lyanna
which is interesting because we all know
Daenerys is actually John's on John
looks at Dany and says she was abducted
by her brother Rhaegar Targaryen
Daenerys says she has heard the story
many times she says she never understood
why Rhaegar would do such a thing
because everyone always told her about
how Rhaegar was a good man and loved by
many abducting a woman does not sound
like something he would do John looks
kind of sad and he says it really
doesn't matter now they're both dead and
there's nothing we can do to change that
then as we see John and Daenerys walking
back out of the crypts they noticed some
commotion happening at the main gate
John can see that his tormund Giantsbane
who nearly collapses as he gets off his
horse the horse appears to be ready to
collapse as well it's obvious they have
been riding non-stop through the night
and day tormund Giantsbane is very
distressed
he tells John about what happened that
he's watched by the sea and Castle black
he confirms the night king does have the
dragon and he will be heading their way
Winterfell was now on high alert Tyrion
Lannister is watching all of this from
above we then follow him inside the
castle and down one of the hallways he
enters his own chamber and closes the
door behind him we see him begin to
write a letter but we don't know who he
is writing that letter to in the final
scene of the episode we see a small boy
working outside in the snow with his
father after watching them for a few
moments the boy suddenly stops the
father will ask him what's wrong the boy
will motion to the nearby forest it's
getting very dark outside so we don't
notice anything at first but then we
begin to see blue eyes staring back at
us
before we know it there are hundreds of
blue eyes moving through the woods the
father tells his son run inside and tell
the others a horn begins to blow as
hundreds of whites begin to run straight
for the father standing outside little
Ned umber who is followed by several
soldiers begin to rush outside to defend
the castle as hundreds of soldiers begin
to rush outside the sound of a dragon
begins to drown out the sound of the
horns that were blowing one of the
soldiers tries to get Ned umber to run
back inside but it's already too late
thousands of White's led by White
Walkers and Giants are now just a few
feet away then the knight King appears
through the clouds and Viserion begins
unleashing
is blue flame on the castle chaos erupts
in every man woman and child begin to
get butchered simultaneously vissarion's
blue flame delivers a devastating blow
that completely destroys the umbers
ancestral home ned umbers personal guard
is butchered within seconds leaving him
all alone on the field one of the white
walkers approaches him and with one
swift move he Pierce's his heart with
the ice sword
Ned umber Falls as we see the night king
landing his dragon we can now see there
are almost 100 white walkers walking
across the blood-soaked battlefield
every man woman and child lay slain at
their feet we get a close-up of the
night King as he raises his arms then
the episode's gonna end with us knowing
what's about to happen next
you
the opening scene of the second episode
will begin in the north at Winterfell
Davos Gendry and the remaining forces
arrive at the main gate they agreed to
stay behind what the ships so they can
unload all the dragon glass from
Dragonstone then escort at the
Winterfell they have about a dozen big
wagons filled with dragonglass most of
the wagons are full of black obsidian
but we can also see there is a wagon
full of green and red dragon glass once
again we can see Arya and Brienne
outside training in the courtyard as the
wagons are arriving at the main gate
they are interrupted as all the wagons
are being brought inside to the center
of the courtyard this is when Aria and
Gendry will notice each other from
across the yard neither one of them can
believe what they are seeing because
they never thought they would actually
see each other again Aria and ginjury
meet in the middle of the courtyard
where they embrace each other for
several moments with a big smile on her
face
arya says I cannot believe you're here I
did not trust that red witch I thought
she was taking you away to murder you
and Gendry says she wanted to sacrifice
me this is when Genji looks over at
davos who has help and unload the wagons
of dragonglass and says I would not be
alive if it were not for him
then Gendry says thanks to the red woman
i found out why the gold cloaks wanted
me so bad I am Robert Baratheon's
bastard son that's why the gold cloaks
wanted me and that's why the red woman
wanted me I have Kings blood Arya looks
stunned for a few moments then she says
you know I wanted to kill the red wix4
taking you away
I used to recite her name every night
before I would fall asleep
Gendry smiles then arya says if I ever
see Melisandre again but before she can
finish her sentence Davos cuts her off
as he walks over and says I will kill
her myself this will be a nice segue
right into my next scene in volantis we
see there as a large group of followers
gathered right outside the red temple
vellore Melisandre can vara and several
other high-ranking members are standing
at the top of the steps overlooking the
crowd this is when Melisandre will say
there is a darkness falling over
Westeros and soon it could cover us all
the Lord of Light has brought all of us
here for one purpose and one purpose
only to end that darkness can vera walks
forward and says Melisandre has already
brought ice and fire together
I believe daenerys targaryen is the one
who will lead us through this darkness
but Melisandre says there is another
then Melisandre says I have already seen
it in the flames
whenever I look for the answers from our
Lord of Light all I can see is snow
Daenerys Targaryen has her own part to
play but Jon Snow will be the one who
defeats the night king Kim vara says
prince or princess it doesn't matter
Melisandre is right the great other is
here to bring the darkness to us all we
must go to Westeros and help them all of
us in the next scene we will go to
Castle black where we will see the
aftermath of the attack from the army of
the Dead Castle black is now in ruins
but there are some survivors from that
attack Lord Commander II D as well as
95% of the remaining members of the
Nights Watch are dead but beric
Dondarrion and a few others are still
alive we will see beric Dondarrion begin
to burn all the whites with his flaming
sword
beric Dondarrion will then say he has to
ride south right away he also says he
made a promise to someone that he would
see them again he has yet to surf his
final purpose if you remember at the end
of season seven Barrack did say to
another character they would meet again
so we shall see now let's go to another
scene back in Winterfell
Brian Stark is sitting alone in the
godswood next to the weirwood tree we
can see that his hands are gripping the
chair as his eyes are fluttering back
and forth in his head then we will be
thrust into a series of visions bran
stark is having we see Jaime Lannister
taking off his helmet during the first
time we saw him arriving at Winterfell
we see Ned Stark statue in the crypts of
Winterfell we see and hear the Mad King
saying burned them all we see the stache
a wild fire underneath King's Landing we
see blue dragon fire burning a castle
that's covered in snow we can see a bed
covered in blood we see bran stark
falling from the broken tower we see
smoke rising from Winterfell we see
Melisandre looking into the flames we
see a black silhouette as someone
standing on a battlefield holding a
burning sword in their hand we can hear
the sound of a baby crying inside of a
tower then bran will see himself
standing face to face with the night
king and this immediately throws him out
of the vision as we get closer to the
end and the night king gets closer to
Winterfell there can
action and their powers will continue to
grow stronger and stronger when brain
stark looks up we see he is surrounded
by John Davos Daenerys Sansa and Arya
they all want to know what brain has
seen bran says everything I can see
everything at first it was all fragments
making it very hard to decipher what was
past present or even future events but
now he knows brain says Castle black is
gone along with its men the last hearth
is gone along with all the umbers men
then brain says I saw the night King he
knows we're all here he will be here
soon John tells everyone to meet him in
the main hall bran grabs John by his arm
right as he's about to walk away Bryan
says we need to speak soon it's finally
time you know the truth this gets the
attention at the Narus and Sansa they're
both wondering what bran meant by that
every one of importance is gathered
inside the main hall of Winterfell Jon
Snow informs everyone of the recent
attacks in the north by the night king
everyone in the room is silent John says
Cersei Lannister has yet to send us any
additional soldiers to fight the army of
the dead but what they're without her
they have to prepare for what's to come
they will need to reinforce all the
walls of the castle they will need to
hand out dragonglass weapons to every
man woman and child at Winterfell John
says the castle should not fall my
father always said 500 men could hold
Winterfell against 10,000 if the castle
should fall there are secret passageways
below the ground that can help them
escape from the north but let's hope it
doesn't come to that then John holds up
long cloth for everyone to see he says
this sword is made of Valyrian steel
I have already defeated several White
Walkers with this sword they have
control over the army of the Dead and
the night King has control over them if
we can take out the White Walkers in the
night King we might be able to defeat
the entire army I will go for as many
White Walkers as I can with Longclaw but
I'm gonna need your help
this is when Arya and Brienne will stand
up at the same time they both mentioned
they also have Valyrian steel weapons
and they will stand by John to help him
defeat the White Walkers and the night
King Samwell Tarly stands up as well he
informs John about his father's sword
hearts Bane Sam also says he has been
reading
some of the old books that he took from
the Citadel he says he may have found
some information that may be of interest
Tyrion Lannister will shift in his seat
he looks to sam wall and says i would
like to see those books as well as
everyone begins to leave the hall
Daenerys tells John she would like to
speak with him alone songs who looks at
Daenerys suspiciously as does Terry
Lannister
Jonathan Aerys then walk atop the castle
overlooking the battlements
Daenerys wants to know when Jon's gonna
tell everyone about their relationship
John doesn't think that's a good idea
right now considering how many other
northern lords and ladies still do not
trust an heiress he doesn't need anyone
to lose focus or abandon their cause
right before the army of the Dead arrive
they should wait until after the battle
is over we can't afford to lose anyone
right now it doesn't look like Cersei is
sending us any of her soldiers we
already lost the Nights Watch in the
umbers let's discuss this again after
the battle rate as John begins to walk
away Daenerys says wait there's one more
thing I spoke to your Masoner last night
I told him I haven't been feeling very
well lately and he decided to examine me
to see what the issue could be John
looks nervous he says is everything okay
what's the matter
after a long silence Daenerys says John
I'm pregnant now let's go to another
scene Jaime and Bronn arrive at the
twins the castle looks nearly abandoned
now Jaime says someone infiltrated their
castle killed Walder Frey and almost
every other loyal man to House Frey bran
notices that no one is guarding their
bridge Jaime says if only Robb Stark
would have found their birds this way he
would still be alive and I would most
likely be dead bran slaps Jaime on the
shoulder and says if only dreams came
true when Jaime and Bronn reached the
castle doors they are greeted by several
of the Frey daughters who are now in
charge of the twins Jaime says we are
now heading north and he needs to gather
any soldiers our men that they have
available there is a storm coming down
from the wall and everyone will die
unless they follow him north one of the
Frey girl says Queen Cersei did not
inform us of this why did we not receive
a raven Jaime says she sent me instead
speaking of Cersei Lannister we go back
to King's Landing in the next scene
Cersei Qyburn and the mountain are
walking around the wall
the red key Qyburn has men burning up
the stashes a wildfire to place at each
gate that enters the city along with
many other locations no one will enter
through any of the city gates without
getting burned alive we can also see
they are strategically setting up large
ballistas all around the city
King's Landing will not fall as easily
as it did during season eight Circe says
Daenerys Targaryen may have the larger
army right now but we shall see how
large that army is after the dead get
through with them Cersei vows that
Daenerys will never step foot inside the
red keep while she is still alive
Cersei also says even if we lose we have
seen what fire does to the army of the
Dead with the amount of wildfire we have
I'm not concerned with anyone or
anything taking over the city while I'm
here now that I have the iron banks full
support I may have one other surprise
for our dragon queen the next scene
takes place in the middle of the night
Theon Greyjoy and his small team of men
land their boats on the shore of the
Iron Islands and make their way up to
the castle Theon is hope and a sister
Yara is being kept captive there he
wants to free Yara before Euron
eventually has her killed but to their
surprise the Iron Islands are completely
abandoned there isn't even anyone there
guarding the castle Euron has taken
every able body to fight with him and
those who could not fight were put to
the blade yarr is not there Theon's
worst fear has come true
Yara stolen the silence and in order to
set her free
Theon's gonna have to board that wicked
ship now let's go to the next scene this
time we go to Dragonstone we can see
Euron's entire fleet is scattered around
the island now that Daenerys has taken
all of her men north
urines men along with the golden company
were able to easily secure the castle
for Cersei Lannister on board the
silence we go down below where we can
see yar a Greyjoy she's covered in blood
and it looks like most of her hair has
been chopped off your own Greyjoy enters
the cabin and he begins laughing like a
maniac right in yars face he informs
Jorah that she's not gonna make it off
his ship alive and he assures her that
Theon's never gonna have the balls to
try to get her back and even if he did
he's gonna hang both of them from the
front of the silence then he leans down
and whispers tell me my sweet niece who
your king Yarra doesn't say a word but
she does not break eye contact for a few
moments it's silent then Euron begins
laughing like a maniac again and he
throws something that bounces off a yars
face we soon find out why Yura hasn't
said a word Euron has said Yara with her
own tongue what she had chopped off
almost immediately after her capture now
we go back to Winterfell where Jon
Daenerys bran
Sam Tyrion and the maester are looking
over everything he took from the Citadel
their hope and they can find out some
more information about how to defeat the
night king sam says he has several books
and Scrolls about the long night the
White Walkers and the children of the
forest and many others the only problem
is he's having trouble making sense of
it all Brian Stark says show me what you
found then perhaps I can go back and
have a look for myself tyrion lanister
grabs one of the books that is already
open this one has legends about the long
night and he begins to read it aloud it
has information about a legendary figure
known as a Zora high who carried a
burning sword called light bringer
tyrion looks over at Jonathan Harrison
says this reminds me of what Melisandre
said to us on Dragonstone
Melisandre said the prince who was
promised will bring the dawn but
missandei believes it could mean the
prince or princess who will bring the
dawn this is or a high figure sounds
like a man bran Stark says old nan used
to tell me bedtime stories about a last
hero who would lead the fight against
the dead then the maester cuts in and
says well where do you suppose we find
such a man with a magical burning sword
Sam immediately looks over at Jon Jon
says a long Clause of Valyrian steel but
it does not burn Jon looks over to bran
and says what do you think this could
mean brain says I need to go to the
godswood in the final scene of the
episode we will see a massive storm
begin to roll in from the north everyone
in the area begins to go indoors the
location of the castle is revealed when
we see the Karstark banners hanging by
the main gate
Alysse Karstark is inside with a few of
her household guards she's sitting by
the fire reading some of the messages
the Ravens brought in for the day she
says word has arrived from Winterfell
Castle black and the last hearth no long
stand the night king and the army of the
Dead may be on their way to Winterfell
next they inform us that we should all
get the Winterfell as soon as we can
they say we should prepare for the worst
before she can finish telling her men
about the news from Winterfell a sudden
scream and the sound of a horn begin to
echo through the castle
Elise Karstark runs over to the window
to have a look outside to see where the
scream came from to her surprise she
cannot see anything now it's a complete
whiteout from the storm then all of a
sudden a thunderous scream comes from
the clouds above the night king and
Viserion
suddenly appeared through the storm the
episode ends as a blue flame can be seen
lighting up the night sky we now know
how scarce dark will also be added to
the army of the Dead
you
this episode will begin with us getting
a glimpse of the aftermath of that
attack there is smoke rising from a
mound of stone which is where the castle
once stood we can see that there are a
KERS and acres of snow-covered land and
soaked in blood
there's also remnants and northern
uniforms all over the ground as well as
broken weapons this looks like your
typical battlefield the only difference
is there are no dead bodies
we know the night king has risen demo to
fight in his army and they're most
likely heading to Winterfell which is
where we will have our next scene back
in Winterfell we will see hundreds of
northern men preparing the Starks castle
for the coming storm outside of the main
gate of the castle we will see them
making trenches that appear to be a moat
just like in season 8 I want to enclose
the castle in a ring a fire that will
prevent the dead from entering
Winterfell I actually talked about this
idea in one of my videos before the
final season came out we're also gonna
see hundreds of archers on standby all
along the top of the wall of the castle
all of their arrows are made of
dragonglass there's also going to be
barrels of these arrows all along the
top of the castle walls as well down in
the courtyard there are thousands of
Spears made up of dragonglass
- however great worms spear will look
slightly different than the rest his
will be made with the red dragon glass
we're also gonna see that ginjury has
made himself a new hammer out of
dragonglass and there will be different
spikes coming off the hammer each of the
spikes will be made up of different
coloured dragonglass one black one red
in one green John
Sansa Arya and ghost are walking around
the courtyard overlooking all the work
getting done to their home arya mentions
how she came across Nymeria on her way
to Winterfell arya tells John I did want
her to come home with me but deep down I
knew that she was meant to be free she
hopes that one day she's gonna be able
to see her again as John looks over at
ghost you can see that he has a sad look
on his face realizing that ghost is the
only direwolf left in the far north John
talks about the day they were found and
how he told Ned they were meant to have
them he also says as long as they're
alive they're always going to have a
connection to one another no matter how
much distance is in between them
this brings a smile to arias face and
John says even at times when him and
ghosts were separated he would always
have a sense that he was still with him
and Aria says I have also felt that with
Nymeria they are interrupted within one
of the guards at the main gate begins to
shout that a writer is approaching the
castle beric Dondarrion has arrived from
Castle black barrack looks like he's
about to collapse as John tells the
guards to open the gate and allow him
inside
as soon as arya recognizes who it is she
draws out her dagger arya lets beric
know right away that he is not welcome
and John looks somewhat confused arya
says barracks old gandrayda Melisandre
knowing full well that the red witch
wanted to sacrifice him beric Dondarrion
will say kill me if you must but I'm
here to play my part in the Great War
then barrack looks at John and says the
night king and the army of the Dead will
be here tonight the next scene is in
King's Landing it begins with your own
Greyjoy greeting Cersei Lannister
Euron says I have completed every
mission you have set upon me I have
travelled the seas conquered your
enemies and even brought you the golden
company Cersei says you haven't defeated
all of my enemies but maybe it is time
you are rewarded your own smiles then
the commander of the golden company
greets Cersei he talks about how good it
feels to be in Westeros
Cersei reminds him not to get too
comfortable they still have a war to win
harry strickland then wishes to speak to
whoever commands Cersei Lannister
soldiers he wants to discuss their
strategy Cersei informs him that she is
in the process of finding someone she
can trust who can command her Lannister
men her former commander and brother has
left the city for good she says he went
to go join his traitor brother the
bastard in the north and the foreign
[ __ ] with the Dragons
Cersei then says but it doesn't matter
now I have everything I need right here
Euron has a very big smile come across
his face even though Cersei wasn't just
talking about him we also see Cersei
noticed the look when Harry Strickland's
face as the Dragons were mentioned she
can tell he's very nervous about those
dragons so Cersei says what's wrong are
you afraid of dragons Harry says he
wasn't entirely sure they were even real
he's heard about them for quite some
time yet he has never seen them for
himself afterwards euron greyjoy wishes
to speak with Cersei alone the scene
ends a Cersei says as you wish back in
Winterfell bran
John De Niro
Sam Tyrion and the maester are shown in
the godswood
Tyrion Lannister says there must be
someone or something that has a
connection to all the different legends
about the long night as we saw in the
last episode the book about the long
night talks of azor Ahai Melisandre
talks about the prince who has promised
an old nan used to speak of the last
hero during her bedtime stories and all
these different stories it is said that
these legendary figures have faced the
darkness and one sam looks over at bran
and says we need you to go back and see
if there is anything you can tell us
about this man who was he how did he
defeat the White Walkers we need answers
bran stark will take a deep breath then
his eyes will roll back in his head he's
about to see another series of visions
somes going to take place in the past
some in the present and even the future
this time the very first thing he sees
is a black silhouette standing alone on
a battlefield holding a burning red
sword it's very similar to his last
vision of the shadowy figure only this
time the man is standing face to face
with the night king then bran will see
the same battlefield but now no one is
there and all the snow is gone bran
stark is walking across that battlefield
then he sees a man facedown in the water
he can also see there are some red
rubies scattered all across the water
then he begins to see a crowd of people
cheering there is a man mounted on a
horse and he leans down and hands
something to a girl who looks a lot like
his sister Arya then brain is at the
wall there is a lot of blood covering
the snow when brain looks into the blood
he can see blue rose petals scattered
throughout it soaking up the blood
now bran is back at the Tower of joy but
this time he can see leona is sitting up
in the bed talking to a man with hair so
blond that it almost looked silver bran
knows it's Rhaegar and he can hear him
say our son has a song and it is the
Song of Ice and Fire
Bryan then sees a woman dressed in red
with hair as red as a bleeding star it
appears as if this woman is talking to
someone but brain can't quite make out
the man's face it sounds like John's
voice but all he can see is a black
silhouette with smoke rising from the
sword then all of a sudden brain is back
on the battlefield that is now covered
in snow once again bran can see the
figure that looks like a black
silhouette with a burning sword clenched
in his fist
time he's standing face-to-face with the
night king right his brain sees the
night king take a step forward the black
shadowy figure swings his sword as fast
as lightning strikes when brand opens
his eyes we can see that he has
completely covered in sweat was steam
coming off his body everyone else that's
in the godswood are silently staring at
brand anxiously awaiting to find out
what he has seen Tyrion says are the
legends real after a few moments of
silence sam says do you know what we
need to do to defeat the night king
after a few more moments of silence
brian finally says yes now it all makes
sense I finally understand what the
three-eyed Raven was trying to show me
sam says what what is it this scene ends
as bran looks over at Jon back in King's
Landing Cersei the mountain and euron
greyjoy
enter her private chambers Euron
immediately says he wants the mountain
to leave so they can speak alone but
Cersei says don't worry he won't say a
thing
Euron begins by telling Cersei it's time
that he gets what is owed which we all
know he once Cersei herself
Euron then starts bragging about how
he's a better man than Jaime and how
Jaime will never be coming back to
King's Landing unless his head is on a
spike
Cersei does agree but she continues to
play hard to get however Euron does
eventually get Cersei to start to soften
up a bit Cersei knows exactly what
you're on once but she tells him she's
already pregnant with Jaime's child
inside of her Euron says he doesn't care
if she's pregnant he says all he's ever
wanted was to marry the most beautiful
woman in the Seven Kingdoms which is why
he's here
he's a king who deserves to have a queen
at his side they should rule Westeros
together and he also says he's never
gonna betray her or abandon her in a
time of need Cersei does enjoy the
attention she's getting from him but she
isn't quite ready to just hand over the
keys to our kingdom she does however
assure him that he won't get everything
he wants in due time Cersei then motions
for the mountain to step outside
Cersei closes the door behind him then
takes your on by the hand and walks them
over to the bed in the next scene we go
back to Winterfell where we see Jon push
and bran across the courtyard bran says
it's time that him and Jon go speak
alone they begin to make their way to
the crypts of Winterfell but then they
notice some of the guards shouting down
from
the castle wall one of the guards yells
to John and says there are more riders
approaching the main gate this time
there are hundreds and maybe even
thousands once again brands gonna have
to wait to talk to John before John can
even ask who's approaching some of the
guards begin to pick up their weapons
and draw back their bows he can hear
everyone shouting this sends everyone in
the courtyard into a frenzy then we
begin to hear some of the guards
shouting the word Kingslayer with many
other curse words to follow Jaime bran
and the soldiers they were able to
gather have finally arrived they were
able to find roughly a thousand men who
were still scattered throughout the
Riverlands Tyrion does seem to be
surprised that Jaime's in Winterfell not
wearing the Lannister colors he also
notices none of the men with him are
from the Lannister army something has
obviously gone wrong Jaime and Bronn are
greeted with zerah courtesy
Sansa wants to know what the hell's
happening why is Jaime here with
soldiers from House Frey the northerners
are very angry some of which who are
still shouting Kingslayer the North
remembers etc Jon Snow attempts to quiet
everyone down
he says the Jaime where are the
Lannister soldiers Cersei said she would
send before Jaime can even answer songs
emotions - Jaime's sword and says that
was Joffrey's sword it was a wedding
gift from Jamie's father then she says
Jon that was made from father's sword
ice we noticed that Brienne is afraid of
what might happen next
so she steps in between them Brienne
says the Jaime's no longer the same man
that he once was he not only saved my
life on multiple occasions but he also
helped me save yours
she says Jaime gave me the sword and the
suit of armor to protect my own life and
yours you're right
Jaime does have half a Ned Stark's sword
but he also gave me the other half and
specifically said take Ned Stark's sword
to protect Ned Stark's daughters Jaime
then interrupts and says I mean you no
harm
I've only come here to help you fight
the army of the dead when that is done I
shall leave surprisingly miss silence is
everyone but then Jamie pulls out his
sword and that is followed by a hundred
northerners pulling out there's one of
them shouts go ahead Kingslayer give me
a reason to cut you in half like your
brother I will kill you where you stand
Jaime says
I was only getting the sword out to give
it back he looks at Songza and says you
can have your father's sword then he
looks at John and says but I was hoping
I could use it to defend the realm I
know the Lannisters are no friends of
the north I know I have done many things
bad things that I really wish I could
take back but I can't all I can do now
is be a man of my word and I remember
promising you that I would help you win
this war so here I am with a thousand
other soldiers to help you my sister
will not be sending any men which is why
I left and rallied up as many men as I
could on my own Joran Greyjoy light as
well he's not on his way to the Iron
Islands he was actually heading to Essos
to pick up 20,000 mercenaries to add to
Circe's army she intends on fighting in
defeating whoever survives the war in
the north which now includes me I might
add when Daenerys here Circe lied she
gives Terry in a venomous look Varys
puts his head down and walks away John
finally addresses Jaime he says you know
I don't like you sir from the moment I
met you standing right where we are
I've not liked you since she
disrespected me in my own home
he then motions the Jaime and Bronn and
tells them to come inside but the other
thousand men are gonna have to set up
outside other castle walls none of them
are allowed to enter until everything is
sorted out inside everyone then gathers
inside a Winterfell main hall as always
Lord Glover and Yan Royce are by far the
loudest voices in the room they give
John a stern warning if they allow this
man to set up shop in the north he will
slit everyone's throat while they sleep
you cannot trust a Lannister Lord Royce
threatens to take the Knights of the
Vale back to the Eyrie he doesn't want
to fight alongside the Kingslayer or
even the Targaryen for that matter
unfortunately this causes other Lords to
stand up and begin to say the same thing
they're all wanting to march their men
home and wait out the coming storm
that's until John slams his fist into
the table and yells enough John says I
already made it known that I would not
force anyone to stay here and fight but
I promise you if you leave you will die
we either fight together or die divided
this is the only way John says I have no
love for the Lannisters they're
responsible for the death of my father
brother and Lady Stark I want them here
no more
any of you but we need men I have stood
face-to-face with the night king I know
what he's capable of none of you have
seen the army of the Dead but you will
soon enough when you do you will be
thankful for any and every man standing
by your side trust me we're all gonna
need it
finally Jaime Lannister stands up to
address the room first he apologizes to
John for what has happened to him and
his family he swears he had nothing to
do with Ned Stark's death or the red
wedding Jaime looks around the room for
Varys
because he knows Varys knows Joffrey had
Ned Stark killed on his own but to
everyone's surprise Varys is gone no one
has seen him since he walked away after
finding out Cersei wasn't sending any
additional support right as everyone's
focused shifts from Jamie to Varys in
comes bran stark Jamie gets very nervous
he knows everything's about to blow up
in his face we can see that brain is
being led into the hall by his sister
Arya Stark once she gets bran sitting
next to John and Sansa she walks up to
Jaime and says what's wrong you look a
little frightened Arya says you might
not remember me Kingslayer but I
remember you she looks over at bran and
says I remember you - the last time I
saw the both of you you are celebrating
with Walder Frey you were celebrating
the fact that she had retaken my
mother's childhood home as well as
killing our uncle the blackfish she
looks back at Jaime and says do you
remember here let me help you
Arya then removes something from the bag
that has slung over her shoulder all of
a sudden Arya now appears to be the same
serving girl that was flirting with
Jaime at the twins Jaime and Bronn are
both stunned this even gets John's
attention he's wondering what the hell's
happening Arya then removes the dagger
from her belt as several men walk up
behind Jaime and Bronn with their swords
drawn Arya says is there anything else
you would like to say to my family
Kingslayer
Jaime's eyes are filling up with water
Jaime doesn't say a word
but he looks at bran and notices brain
is staring a hole right through him for
a few moments Jaime silent struggling to
find the right words to say but then
right as the tension is reaching an
all-time high
and finally says something he says I
know it was you
Lord Glover stands up and demands that
brain tell everyone what he knows about
the Kingslayer
brains eyes never leave Jamie after a
few more moments
Sansa stands up and demands that brains
say something as well Jamie who's crying
at this point looks at sons and says no
need my lady I will tell you everything
Jamie walks to the center of the room he
looks around at all the stark children
he says I am truly sorry I do not expect
anyone to forgive me for what I'm about
to say Tyrion looks at bran
he's certain he knows what's about to
come next deep down he's always new but
now he realizes he might also die for
the crimes of his family then after a
few more moments of silence Jamie opens
his mouth to confess but they are
suddenly interrupted by the sound of a
horn coming from outside the sound sent
chills throughout the room it is time
the dead have finally arrived
Winterfell Hall erupts into chaos Jon
immediately orders everyone outside and
those who cannot fight or to head for
the crypts below to flee the north they
were ready for this Jon had maps drawn
up at the secret tunnel so everyone knew
the escape route as Jon gets outside he
signals for the trenches to be lit which
will enclose Winterfell in a ring of
fire preventing the dead from getting
inside Jon hands widows well back to
Jamie and he says if you have any shred
of on or left come prove it by fighting
alongside me on the battlefield
within seconds they find themselves
standing outside in a complete whiteout
they're only able to see within a few
feet of their faces Jon also wants to
marys to go underground now that she's
pregnant he doesn't want to risk her
getting injured
Daenerys refuses to sit out the fight
she says they're not gonna survive
without her endurance help Jon really
has no option but to let her fight he
knows how effective jorgen is when
Daenerys is on his back this is when we
will see Daenerys mountains rogue on and
take to the sky however we're not able
to see much because of the whiteout Jon
then goes to the top of the wall in
hopes of getting a glimpse of the army
of the Dead for a few moments he's not
able to see any further than a few feet
in front of him
but then he starts to see the faint
glimmer of blue eyes in the distance
he's not able to see their bodies but at
this point he can see there are
thousands of blue eyes staring back at
him and they're not just in front of the
castle they have the entire castle
surrounded by the dead by now the snow
is getting so deep that authority are
not able to ride their horses most other
forces are outside the walls john hopes
they are able to defend themselves in
that storm
Brian Stark attempts to use the Ravens
so he can see where the night king is at
but the birds are not taking flight in
the storm the night king storm
essentially blocks bran from taking
control of any animals all of a sudden
we begin to hear the screams of
thousands of dead men as they get closer
to the castle the sound of them running
almost sounds like a thunder storm the
battle has officially begun Jon Snow
Sandor Clegane Brienne Jaime Lannister
grey worm Jorah Mormont
tormund Gendry and Arya head out into
the storm all of the Valyrian steel
weapons will now be on the battlefield
once they get outside the main gate the
rest of the pitch is ignited completing
the Ring of Fire around the castle John
and the others are not going to be able
to escape back to the castle if need be
their destiny now lies ahead of them as
they enter the battle they are
determined on stopping the night King
tonight the faint glow of drogon and
Regan's flames can be seen to the storm
we can only hope that the nurse and her
dragons are finding their targets
just like in season eight the night king
has sent his army ahead of him so he can
sit back and wait for the right time to
strike we are then shown a glimpse of
dozens of White Walkers and Giants
walking onto the battlefield this time
we are gonna see all of the characters
holding Valyrian steel weapons face off
against White Walkers and some epic
sword fights however at some point
during the battle grey worm will be
slain by a white Walker he was able to
kill one of the White Walkers with his
dragonglass spear but due to the limited
visibility he wasn't able to see the
other one closing in on him Daenerys is
able to take out hundreds if not
thousands of whites with each pass of
her dragons but the unsullied Dothraki
and even the northerners are getting
slaughtered in this massive storm
Brienne's lake will be severely wounded
during the attack torment in the Hound
will try dragging her back to the castle
wall but they're also going to come
under attack
Stormin will be killed in the process
John and Jamie are both injured as well
Arya Starks gonna end up getting
surrounded by several whites she's able
to kill most of them but if not for
Jamie shielding her she might have
fallen as well Daenerys will be able to
burn thousands of whites who are dragged
on and ragle but it's not enough to slow
down the attack it's nearly impossible
to see all of them in the storm not to
mention they are surrounding the entire
castle on all sides after nearly every
main character suffers a significant
injury they begin to fall back to the
castle wall although they are still
trapped outside of the Ring of Fire they
are hoping Daenerys can hold them off
while they try to get the injured to
safety meanwhile on the other side of
the castle one of the Giants lays down
on the fire to allow the rest of the
army of the Dead to reach the castle
wall once that happens they will be able
to start climbing the walls or break
down the gate now the night King has
entered the battle vissarion's screams
sounds so much louder than dragons or
agels
Daenerys is finally able to see Jon and
the others near the castle she wants to
attempt to land her dragons so she can
fly the injured somewhere much safer
they are completely exposed outside of
the castles defenses when she lands drag
on one of the White Walkers throws an
ice spear which cuts right through
reagan's wing
this causes ray gall to fly off
erratically as everyone starts to climb
on drug on the sound of vissarion's
scream seems to be getting closer and
his blue flame is getting brighter
through the storm
Daenerys realizes she doesn't have much
time to move and there are too many
people on jorgens back for her to try to
engage the knight King right now instead
of dropping them off inside the
courtyard where she knows the knight
king will surely find them she decides
to leave the castle instead as they are
flying away John looks back at
Winterfell where we can now see there
are thousands of whites climbing over
the castle walls the night King finally
appears through the storm the first
thing he does is burn down the weirwood
tree in the godswood the heart tree that
has been there for roughly eight
thousand years is now up in flames as
they continue to fly away John can only
hope that the rest of his family were
able to make it through the tunnels
underground this episode will end with
the night King landing his dragon right
on top of one fo as he claims the
home of House Stark for himself
you
this episode will begin where we left
off we can see what used to be
Winterfell there is smoke rising from
several different areas of the castle
the battlements are littered with
thousands of dead bodies most of which
are burnt beyond recognition the night
Kings Army is gathered inside of the
castle walls
now although Daenerys was able to do
some significant damage to the night
king's army
he still has a rather large force the
night King and nearly a dozen White
Walkers are seen walking through the
godswood the weirwood tree is now burned
what was once white in red is now
blackened with ash the night King and
his white Walker stand to the side as
one of the Giants knocks over the
weirwood tree crashing it to the ground
the night King and the White Walkers
then head through the courtyard as they
make their way to the crypts of
Winterfell as the night king is walking
through the yard he grabs one of the
weapons that was laying on the ground
the night king examines the dragon glass
almost as if he's inspecting what it's
made of he throws the weapon aside but
then he sets his hand over his chest he
remembers how the children of the forest
created him this may be something you
want to remember for later when the
night King does enter the crypts of
Winterfell he immediately heads for its
lowest level the level that has
partially collapsed it seems as if he
has been here before
he knows exactly where to go he looks
down a tunnel that is still freshly lit
by candlelight he knows that members of
House Stark were able to escape and he
already knows where they're heading next
in the following scene we find out
exactly who was able to escape through
the secret tunnels Sansa bran Tyrion
Davos am gely
baby Sam Musante and several other known
characters this escape route led them
right to the white knife River there are
a few small boats stashed along the
shore they will make their way down the
river until they reach white Harbor
which is where the rest of Danny's fleet
is waiting Davos was chosen to lead the
group if they ever had to use this
option as we all know Davos knows his
way around the waters better than anyone
the map Jon had given them says the wait
at white Harbor until they're able to
regroup with everyone else
Davos tyrion and sam began to help load
everyone onto the small boats as of
right now none of them know if Jon
Daenerys or anyone else for that matter
we're able to escape from Winterfell all
they know is to go to white Harbor and
wait
they finally go to load brain onto the
boat they notice his eyes are rolled
back in his head and his hands are still
gripping his chair
Davos look somewhat nervous him and Sam
have to actually unlock brains grip from
the chair you have to wonder what brain
is seeing at this time in the next scene
Daenerys John Jaime beric the Hound
Brienne arya ginjury and a few others
land at white harbour they have been
flying on drugged on non-stop ever since
they left Winterfell
when they reach land the first thing
John says is everyone else who escaped
had a good head start on them so they
should be making their way down the
river already John wants to leave some
of the injured here at white Harbor with
Danny's fleet while they fly back up the
river in hopes of locating John's family
Daenerys voices are concerned for regal
he hasn't been seen since he was hit by
one of the White Walkers iced beers now
we all know regel obviously still had
the ability to fly but Danny is worried
he may not find them
Jamie happens to be one of the first
ones to volunteer to go with them
although he did suffer some injuries
when he saved Arya he says he doesn't
want to sit around while others head
back out into dangerous territories
Johnson Oh gives him a nod and he thanks
them for helping save Arya John says I
need to get the rest of my family out of
the north immediately Winterfell is gone
along with most of our men we will need
more help if we're ever gonna stop the
night king we cannot allow the night
king to take King's Landing even if it
is Cersei Lannister sitting on the Iron
Throne
Tyrion reminds them there are roughly 1
million people in King's Landing if the
night king manages to add that many to
his army life as we know it will cease
to exist with a very concerned look on
his face John says we need to talk to
your sister again
she must understand we will need the
golden company to help us and we may
need protection behind those walls of
the red key finally John looks at both
Jamie and Tyrion Lannister and says your
sister is our only option in the
following scene Theon Greyjoy in a small
group of men prepared ahead for the
Blackwater Bay now that it's beginning
to get dark outside they had a good
feeling the iron fleet will be there
since it wasn't at the Iron Islands nor
did they come across it out at sea all
they need to do is slip in grab Yara
then get the hell out of there before
any
urines men are alerted as Theon and his
men walk across the beach at Dragonstone
they notice a shadowy figure sitting in
one of their boats
Theon is shocked when he recognizes who
it is it's the spider somehow Varys is
there waiting for them Theon is somewhat
confused because he knows Varys should
be in the north with Daenerys they also
take notice that there are no other
boats in sight in Varys appears to be
completely dry they have no idea how he
has arrived on Dragonstone
when Theon says what are you doing here
all Varys says is I'm coming with you
back in King's Landing
Qyburn meets with Cersei and Euron to
tell them about some recent reports he's
been receiving through his little birds
Qyburn tells them that the Narus
Targaryen z' fleet is at white Harbor
she has abandoned Dragonstone while they
fight in the north her fleet is our only
means of transporting her large force
quickly they also remember that John
said the army of the Dead do not swim
Cersei doesn't want to allow John and
Danny to have a way to flee to the sea
so Cersei tells Llorona take some of the
Wildfire to white Harbor and burn
Danny's entire fleet Euron does agree to
do this but not until after he spends
another night with the Queen in the red
key back in the north we see several
small boats heading down the white knife
River we will focus on brand right as he
opens his eyes after another series of
visions Sam is sitting right next to him
he is the first one to ask brain is
everything okay
bran had been out of it for quite some
time and his hands are starting to
callus from the way he keeps gripping
his chair brain says I'm fine but he
doesn't quite understand why he saw but
he saw this time sam says well what did
you see
maybe I can help you was it the night
king is he getting close to us again
brain says no but then he looks at Gilly
and he says I saw your son everyone on
the boat looks at little Sam then bran
says your son was crying and he was
surrounded by fire everyone on the boat
is now concerned by the tone of branes
voice Gilly wraps her arms tightly
around her son Davos tells Gilly not to
worry they will be at white Harbor soon
enough once they arrive they will
immediately load Gilly and the baby onto
one of Danny's ships and get them out to
sea brand then interrupts by whispering
we won't be getting on any ships jon is
on his way to get us
now then he looks at Becca Gilley and
says does your son like dragons Gilley
doesn't even want to look at brand he's
starting to scare her but before she can
answer a dragon appears through the
clouds we noticed that it has a big hole
in its right wing regel seems to be
following them down the river back at
white Harbor
Daenerys John and Jamie get ready to
leave at dawn so they can find the rest
of the survivors John tells beric and
the Hound to find some food to make sure
everyone gets something to eat they may
not have many chances after they leave
Arya is seen helping Brienne clean out
the injury on her leg then get it
wrapped up one of the whites had buried
a sword deep into her thigh as of right
now she can barely stand let alone fight
the how notice is already helping
Brienne he walks over to them and
jokingly says I hope you're not asking
her for mercy because she won't give you
any then he says most men would die from
an injury like that but I'm sure you
will have your sword up someone's arse
in no time by now the Sun is starting to
rise
John Danny and Jamie walk over to climb
on Dragon's Back John looks back at arya
and says if we're not back by sundown we
need to have everyone board a ship then
head to Dragonstone the night king will
never be able to get his entire army to
that island it will be much safer there
we need to find songs of bran and the
rest of the others as soon as possible
we cannot stay here for very long John
and Arya embrace each other one last
time before he leaves the scene will end
as we see drogon disappear into the
clouds in the following scene Cersei and
Euron are laying in bed together Cersei
is still asleep but Euron is starting to
wake up he rolls over and looks at
Cersei he starts to run his finger
across her lips then he moves his hand
further and further down until it's
under the blankets Euron puts his hand
between Circe's thighs he can feel a
wetness on his fingertips when he pulls
his hand out from under the blanket he
can see that his fingers are covered in
blood
he immediately rips the blankets off
Cersei he can now see that most of the
bed is covered in blood as well
Cersei wakes up when she feels the cold
air hit her naked body she can see Euron
standing over her with a strange look on
his face
Cersei then sits up and is suddenly
horrified by what she sees this is when
she will begin to scream and cry the
mountain runs into the room with his
sword drone expecting to see Cersei in a
struggle
Euron immediately raises his hand but
the mountain walks right past him he
grabs one of the sheets covers it over
Cersei then carries her out of the room
Euron then gets dressed leaving the room
with a wicked smile on his face as he's
walking across the throne room one of
the Lannister guards walks up to him and
tells him there is something that he
needs to see we follow them outside and
the guard begins to lead him to the
water when Euron gets close enough to
the bay he stops in his tracks he
appears to be shocked by what he sees
almost all of his iron fleet are gone
the silence is still there but that's
about it Euron quickly boards the
silence there are several men laying on
the deck with their throats slit when
you're on enters the main cabin he
notices Yara's gone there is a dagger
sticking into the wall with a note left
under it written in blood all the note
says is what is dead may never die
sign Yara Greyjoy Euron removes the
dagger and the note from the wall he
turns around and calmly says to the
Lannister guard
how does someone sneak into the
Blackwater Bay and make off with an
entire fleet without someone noticing
before the Lannister guard can even
mutter a single word you're on jams the
dagger into the man's neck Euron leaves
the silence heading back into the city
then we will see you're on meet with a
few men from the city watch they head to
the chambers of the commander of the
golden company when they enter the room
though they notice it's empty as well he
tells the captain of the city watch to
gather up all of his men they need to
find Harry Strickland immediately they
should check every brothel every Inn or
anywhere they think they might be we
will then begin to see some quick scenes
of the city watch entering every home
and establishment within the city not
only is Harry Strickland gone but it
appears as if the golden company has
also left euron greyjoy is furious he
orders the captain to bring him every
single man that was on watch last night
either these men are extremely
incompetent or they were paid off no it
doesn't matter what happened they will
all have to die for this back on
Dragonstone Theon has nearly a hundred
men gathering up as much dragonglass as
they can find that is still left over in
the caves
they will be leaving very shortly to
head north Theon now has an entire fleet
with over 20,000 men from the golden
company varus is seen with a smile on
his face it's obvious he has been up to
something but we don't know what just
yet
when Theon exits the cave he will walk
over to his sister Yara after looking at
her for several moments his eyes begin
to fill up with water he can see Yara's
covered in blood with bruises all over
her body
Theon also knows that Euron had her
tongue removed finally Theon says Yara
I'm sorry I'm so sorry I left you I'm
sorry for what he has done to you but I
promise you this we will get our
vengeance Yara steps in closer and wraps
her arms around her brother she's upset
but ultimately thankful to still be
alive Varys and the commander of the
golden company are now standing side by
side Harry Strickland will reach out the
shake varus's hand he says it's good to
see you again my old friend
Ilario told me you would eventually come
for us one day but I wasn't entirely
sure if you were still alive before they
can finish their conversation they both
noticed several ships approaching the
beach all of the men on the beach begin
to scramble for their weapons they have
been expecting retaliation from your own
Greyjoy but they did not think it would
happen this soon it takes Varys a few
moments to recognize the banners waving
on the ships when they finally stop
flapping in the wind Varys has a fearful
look on his face the banner is
displaying the flaming heart for Varys
this site is even worse than your own
gradually looking for revenge he now
knows Melisandre in Canberra have
arrived he remembers what Melisandre
said to him right before she left as we
see Melisandre and can vara laned on the
beach they begin to walk over to Varys
the red rubies they are both wearing on
their throats are glowing brighter than
ever
Varys can hardly look directly into them
without getting blinded Melisandre
greets him first by saying hello dear
spider can Vera places a hand on Varys
and she says do we still serve the same
queen Varys nods his head kinvaras says
good you're coming with us then all of
you must come with us Jon Snow and
Daenerys Targaryen are no longer in the
far north
Winterfell is gone they will be back at
white Harbor soon but that's not where
we're heading
Varys tell the others it's time to leave
Varys is visibly shaken up by all of
this he doesn't know what to think but
he does feel the urge to do as they say
in the very next scene Daenerys John and
Jaime spot regal in the sky above the
white knife River they also noticed
there are a few small boats directly
below him they found songs of bran and
the rest of the survivors both of the
dragons begin to cry out to each other
Davos will be seen giving a signal to
the other boats they are to head to the
shore to meet with John and Danny right
away after drugged on lands John will
embrace his family when they exit the
boats everyone else begins to climb on
the back of the Dragons they will now
head back to white Harbor to regroup
with everyone else however before they
leave bran tells John they need to speak
as soon as they get back there isn't
much time left we will see the night
King again tonight this scene will end
when the dragons take to the sky back at
white Harbor Arya and ginjury begin
telling everyone to prepare to leave by
now it's starting to get dark and John
said if they won't back by sundown they
work to board a ship and go to
Dragonstone the night King might be
heading this way as we speak we cannot
stay here for very long
beric Dondarrion stands up and says
they're here both dragons come up from
behind them inland arya rushes over to
see who made it out of Winterfell alive
she is relieved when she sees her
brother and sister they all begin
helping everyone off the Dragons when
arya sees Jaime she says thank you for
helping my family then she reaches out
to shake his hand we will see Jon help
bran down from drug on then Jon says
okay let's talk brain says are you sure
you don't want to speak privately John
says no if there is something that I
must know just go ahead and say it now
everyone starts to look at Jon and bran
Sam already knows what's coming next
finally brain says Jon you aren't
exactly who you think you are there is
great power in you that you never knew
existed but I'm sure you've always felt
it John looks somewhat confused then
brain says why do you think you found
ghost why do you think father never
told you who your mother was what do you
think you were brought back from the
dead you have the blood of the Dragon
you have the blood of Ice and Fire
you are the Song of Ice and Fire John
that's why you were chosen none of this
is a coincidence
things were set in motion long before
either you or I were here all of it was
leading to what will happen by the end
of tonight the three-eyed Raven showed
me your birth for a reason it wasn't to
only show me who your parents were it's
because you are the one who will have to
bring the dawn every time I try to look
for answers about how to defeat the
night king all I see are images that
point directly at you Ned Stark was not
your father you are the son of Rhaegar
Targaryen and Lyanna Stark you are the
one who is destined to defeat the night
king everyone now has their eyes set on
John everyone is silent almost as if
they're waiting for something to happen
John seems to be struggling what's
trying to process everything bran just
hold him finally after a few moments Sam
walks closer to John he says it's true
he removes a rolled-up parchment from
his sleeve he hands it to John and he
says it's a record of Rhaegar annulment
with Elia Martell afterwards there was a
secret marriage in Dorne bran has seen
it for himself brain says John you've
never been a bastard you are the
legitimate heir to the Iron Throne your
real name is Aegon Targaryen this new
revelation stuns Daenerys Targaryen her
eyes are now filling up with water she
places her hand over her stomach
Sansa and Arya are now both at a loss
for words brain says I know all of this
might be hard to grasp right now but we
have to leave very soon when all of this
is over you will know that it's the
truth
finally John begins to speak as he
shakes his head he says none of this
makes any sense why didn't father say
something brain says your mother made
him promise he could not allow Robert to
find out who your real father was he
would have murdered you
Rhaegar never kidnapped Liana she loved
him and together they had you Rhaegar
said she would be the Song of Ice and
Fire and he was right that day has
finally come there is only one more
thing you must do in order to defeat the
night king
you will kill him but it won't be here
it's time to go the night king has
already left Winterfell and he's coming
for all of us everyone still seems to be
shocked by the news but they take brains
advice by immediately preparing to leave
most of them had for Danish ships but
Brian tells them to stop he says we
cannot get there by sea we need to fly
there now the night King is on his way
to the trident we must meet him there I
have already seen the battlefield in my
visions the lady in red is on her way
there as well Daenerys says Melisandre
sounding somewhat surprised she then
says I'm not gonna be able to fly
everyone there with Drogo alone half of
you will need to get on Ragle but I'm
not sure how he's gonna react without
having a writer Daenerys and bran both
look at John John shakes his head no
he's never attempted anything like that
before
bran reminds him you have the blood of a
dragon John you're the only other person
here that can do this you have to
believe as I said before there is power
in you and you need to embrace it
Daenerys says brain is right John I
should have known when you and drogon
immediately bonded on Dragonstone
vissarion died trying to save you i
named Ragle after my brother your father
it has to be you who mounts him this is
when John realizes he has no other
choice he walks over to reg all right up
to his face at first he begins to pet
him for a few moments staring into his
eyes hoping to create a bond John then
whispers something to the dragon then he
slowly walks around him and climbs on
top when John sits down raiga lets out a
scream so loud it causes little Sam to
cry ragel then stretches out his wings
and begins to flap them Sansa and Arya
cannot believe what they're seeing
after a few more moments John yells
let's go half of them climb on Joerg on
what Daenerys and the other half climb
on Rhaegar with John they both take
flight heading straight for the trident
in the next scene you're on enter sky
burns lab room he had been examining
Cersei after her miscarriage Cersei has
lost a significant amount of blood
Qyburn was keeping her sedated with milk
of the poppy
Joran informed Cersei of what happened
most of the iron fleet is gone as well
as all of the golden company your
says I now have no reason to stay in the
city he knows Cersei doesn't have nearly
enough Lannister men or city watch to
hold the city for much longer
he says he's taken the silence and
leaving Cersei says wait she sits up and
says I thought you said you were a king
you promised that you would never
abandon me but now you want to leave
because we lost a few boats and some men
we haven't lost the war just yet I still
have one thing they don't
Daenerys said the army of the Dead are
100,000 strong hath patience my king the
dead will crush our enemies for us
Daenerys already lost one dragon she
will lose the rest King's Landing is
well-protected no one will ever enter
through those city gates even if they
did somehow managed to breach them I
will make sure there won't be a city
left my plans were already set in motion
long before you ever arrived in King's
Landing you said you wanted to rule
Westeros together you said you wanted to
crush our enemies together you said you
needed a queen at your side but you're
only a king of the Iron Islands how
about I make you a true King and
together we can watch all of our enemies
burn the final scene of the episode will
end as we see a evil smile come across
your own Greyjoy's face
you
this episode begins as we see Melisandre
can vara and Varys traveling by land
they are leading an enormous party of
over 25,000 soldiers Melisandre and can
vara were able to bring a thousand
soldiers of their own along with several
thousand followers of her lore following
closely behind are Theon Yara and the
commander of the golden company thanks
to varus and Theon they have the twenty
thousand men from the golden company and
some of the Ironborn men before they
left Dragonstone they were able to get
enough dragonglass
to fill a very large wagon but not
nearly enough to arm all of the 25,000
men after watching them travel for a few
moments Melisandre and can vara will
finally find the location they have been
seeing in the flames we are now at the
Trident the same location Robert
Baratheon defeated Rhaegar Targaryen
this is where they will set up camp as
they wait for John Daenerys and the
others to arrive some of the followers
of her lore will begin to make several
massive bonfires alongside the river
everyone watches as Melisandre and can
vara begins speaking in a foreign tongue
as they look into the fire Varys is
visibly shaken he is reminded of what
the sorcerer said as he threw his parts
into the flames he's starting to think
maybe Melisandre is right maybe he will
die in Westeros after all after a few
more moments Melisandre begins speaking
in the common tongue she talks of the
long night and the one who will bring
the donned Melisandre and can vara both
begin chanting again referring to the
great other and the Lord of Light they
finish up by saying the night is dark
and full of terrors but tonight those
terrors will be extinguished forever
Varys is unsettled by all of this as the
day grows darker the Rubies on their
throats continue to glow brighter even
Melisandre eyes are beginning to turn
red kinvaras notices the look on varus's
face she walks over to speak with him
she wants to know was he looking into
the flames as they were chanting
she also says the Varys would you like
me to show you the answers the Lord of
Light has given us Varys doesn't make
eye contact with kin vara he doesn't
want to know but she leans in closer to
Varys anyway and begins to whisper
she says there will be a great battle
here tonight almost every single person
you see here will die before the morning
sunrise we all must make our sacrifices
I will die tonight Melisandre will die
tonight in you Lord Varys will die
tonight
the Lord of Light has given us
protection until now but now we must
protect him in the next scene we go down
to King's Landing there are over a dozen
lords and ladies gathered inside the
Great Hall of the red key Qyburn and
Euron are standing at the top of the
steps right next to the iron throne as
always
Euron is dressed in all black only this
time he has a massive golden crack and
stitched on the back of his long leather
coat after a few moments of silence
Cersei walks in with her escort Gregor
Clegane Cersei is wearing a black gown
with golden trim on the back of her gown
there is a massive golden lion and
Kraken stitched on the back
Qyburn is shown holding two brand-new
crowns that also appear to be displaying
the lion and the Kraken both of the
Crown's are made of solid gold
now that Cersei has lost just about
everything she cannot afford to lose
you're on greyjoy now as sad as that may
sound Jaime Lannister who was once her
brother lover and commander of her
armies is now gone to the other side the
golden company are nowhere to be found
and the rest of her alliances are either
dead or too small to make any
significant impact all she has now is
Yaron Qyburn the mountain in a few
thousand Lannister soldiers and Men of
the city watch not to mention she did
just lose another baby so it's safe to
say she is desperate at this point
although she does somehow remain
confident because according to her she
still has one thing Daenerys Targaryen
does not so as promised in the last
episode Cersei marries euron greyjoy
after Qyburn makes it official we will
see Euron place the new crown on Circe's
head then Cersei will place a new crown
on Euron said making him her king they
don't bother having a feast to celebrate
the occasion they don't even have a
bedding ceremony since Cersei is still
recovering from the miscarriage instead
they go outside to check up on all of
Kings landings defenses all of the
Lannister soldiers are now staying
inside the walls of the red key
the city watts are shown bringing up
more wildfire to place near each gate
that enters the city there are now
roughly 100 ballista strategically
placed around the city of King's Landing
we will see one a chi burns little birds
run over and hand him a note after
reading it
Qyburn announces the sir senior on the
final phase is complete in the following
scene John Daenerys and the others are
flying further south on Drogo and reg
all right before they left white Harbor
brain said they must go to the trident
but he hasn't said exactly where they
should land that's until they spot a
massive force making camp next to the
river they can also see several large
fires burning into the evening sky as
they drop down out of the clouds brain
signals to John that this is the right
location this is where he saw the night
King in the shadowy figure standing
face-to-face on the battlefield as soon
as they land the dragons Daenerys is
immediately greeted by Varys who is
accompanied by the commander of the
golden company Varys apologizes for
leaving the North without notice he
explains how it was necessary so that
his alliance with the golden company was
not revealed otherwise that information
may have made it back to King's Landing
before Varys was able to make it there
himself
Daenerys understands and she even seems
grateful John seems very surprised that
Varys was able to pull this off
they believed that Varys fled so he
could save his own ass this could not
have came at a better time because as
far as they know the only ones to
survive the Winterfell attack are the
ones who just landed on the Dragons
without Varys getting the golden company
or Melisandre and Theon bring in more
men they would have had no chance but to
ask Cersei for protection which we all
know she would never agree to Fiona
informs John and Daenerys that he has
most of Euron's fleet along with several
thousand men of the Ironborn who are now
ready to swear fealty to John and Danny
when Daenerys sees Yara she gives her a
big hug and tells her that she's sorry
for what has happened
Daenerys swears that once they finished
the night king they will kill Cersei
Lannister and Euron Greyjoy next Varys
then begins to tell John and Daenerys
how he came in contact with kin vara and
Melisandre Varys says Melisandre brought
1000 soldiers of the fiery hand as well
as several thousand followers of her
lore
he also tells John and Danny what
kinvaras said about how almost everyone
will die here tonight John doesn't like
the sound of that especially since there
are so many massive bonfires around the
camp he's afraid that can verify -
sacrifices being made in the name of the
Lord of Light he reminds them that the
whole reason Melisandre is no longer in
his service is because she burned
Princess Shireen alive John tells Danny
that he needs to go find Melisandre
right away he needs to keep her and
Davos away from each other until he can
figure everything out he doesn't want to
battle to breakout before the night king
even arrives we followed John over to
the large fire Melisandre and can vara
are surrounded by several soldiers who
are dressed in red from head to toe John
notices the Ruby and Melisandre's
necklace is glowing brighter than he's
ever seen it before
when Melisandre notices Jon walking over
she decides to approach him before he
can say anything in front of everyone
else
John stops in his tracks when they make
eye contact for the first time Jon
actually looks afraid when he notices
Melisandre eyes are now the colour of
blood
Melisandre breaks eye contact to look
down at Jon sword this causes her eyes
to glow brighter but Jon finally says
why are you here
Melisandre says I told you Jon Snow I
can help you defeat the night King you
need me now more than ever
darkness will soon be upon us and we can
no longer run or hide I have seen it in
the flames and your brother has even
seen it in his visions that's why you're
here
all of us will dance in front of the
fires tonight Jon Snow in you most of
all will be victorious there has to be
one last great sacrifice that - I have
seen into flames Jon cuts are off he
says there will be no more sacrifices
Melisandre XY's begin to glow again
causing Jon to look away Melisandre says
do you know what the night king wants
Jon Snow do you know why he has finally
come south the fires behind Melisandre
begin to burn hotter and higher than
before the red ruby on her neck also
begins to shine brighter as well finally
Melisandre says the night King is coming
for his replacement the one he has
chosen is among us now and he will not
stop until he gets what he asked
for Melisandre raises her voice as she
says we must give his replacement to the
fire Jon Snow the great other will not
stop but we must put an end to all the
terrors in the night
Melisandre voice was so loud it has
attracted the attention of almost
everyone in the camp they began to
gather around Jon and Melisandre
once again Melisandre says we have to
give him to the fire Jon Snow
that is our only way we have to make
this great sacrifice if we're going to
stop the night king everyone from Jon's
party is now watching Aria and Davos
walk up the stand directly behind Jon
the tension is beginning to rise
throughout the camp Melisandre and
kinvaras rubies continue to get so
bright that most of the crowd gathered
around have to shield their eyes Davos
tells John that Melisandre should not be
here all of a sudden the chanting stops
the 25,000 soldiers gathered in tendance
near the fires are completely silent
Melisandre has noticed something or
someone standing out in the crowd but no
one is quite sure who she is looking at
next until Melisandre sticks out her
hand and points directly at Gilly and
her baby jon was afraid this might
happen when Davos realizes what
Melisandre is insinuating he grabs arias
dagger off her hip then lunges for
Melisandre snek a few members of the
fiery hand are able to quickly apprehend
him but Davos begins to scream he shouts
Melisandre has already burned one child
he will not stand by and watch as she
burns another Arya is now holding needle
she has always known Melisandre was evil
ever since she took injury away she
would take pleasure in crossing off
another name that was once on her list
Melisandre says I am sorry but this is
the only way you have to bring me that
child the Lord of Light has shown me a
great sacrifice in the flames and I am
his instrument Gendry now has his
dragonglass Warhammer in his hands they
are not about to allow Melisandre to get
her hands on Gilly son Jon is starting
to get very nervous he was afraid a
battle might break out before the night
king showed up the tension across the
camp is now at an all-time high but then
we see bran stark begin to move himself
closer to the fire everyone begins to
settle as they watch brand stop himself
right next to Melisandre a
moments go by as everyone wonders what
will happen next
finally brain begins to speak he says
Melisandre is right there will be a
great sacrifice here tonight I have seen
it in my visions
I did see Gilly son surrounded by the
fires Brian then looks to Gilly and says
your son was meant as an offering to the
night king he was not meant to leave the
north with you and Samwell
your son was going to be the final
sacrifice to the great other but here we
are bran moves closer to Gilly he tells
her he has seen all of this in his
visions he says your son is more special
than you know all of Crestor sons were
offerings to the night king each of them
became one of the night King's personal
guards but your son was meant to be more
than that he would have been the 100th
offering which had him in line to
becoming the next night king the night
King needs newborn babies as his
instruments and they all need to come
from a special bloodline your son comes
from that bloodline you see Craster's
father wasn't just an ordinary man of
the Nights Watch he comes from a
bloodline that stretches back for
thousands of years bran then turns to
Melisandre and Jon he says Melisandre
said there would be a great sacrifice
here tonight she is right like I said I
did see that in my vision Jon but it
won't be Gilly son who gets sacrificed
Brandon looks at Melisandre and says
that great sacrifice will be you you are
the lady in red that I have seen on the
battlefield as brain is telling her this
we begin to see the clouds start to move
and above them we will also notice the
fires are starting to die down it's
getting colder which can only mean one
thing
Jon is noticing all of this which causes
him to alert everyone gathered around
Jon says the night king has brought the
storm he then yells for everyone to grab
their weapons bran grabs Jon by the arm
and says I told you there is great power
in you you have to embrace it I need you
to trust me this is our last chance you
must kill Melisandre if you want to stop
the night King you have to bring the
dawn or we will all die the fires begin
to get brighter again
Melisandre Ruby is getting so hot that
smoke is beginning to rise as it
does her skin Davo yells she murdered
princess Shireen and she wanted to
murder Gilly son Gendry steps in and
says she wanted to kill me too
Jon looks over at Daenerys wondering
what he should do the storm above them
is growing larger and snow is starting
to fall into the fires can Vera is her
chanting to the Lord of Light she
promises they will make the great
sacrifice that he needs bran Davos
Gendry and now Arya are all telling John
to kill Melisandre as Jon reaches for
his sword Melisandre drops to her knees
at that same exact moment vissarion
scream echoes across the battlefield the
night king and his dragon are here
thousands of blue eyes can now be seen
in the distance Samwell Tarly runs over
to Jon while holding his family's
ancestral Valyrian steel sword sam says
Melisandre wanted to murder my son if I
can't kill her myself
I want you to use my family's sword it's
called hearts Bane without hesitation
Jon grabs the sword and he plunges it
deep into Melisandre chest black smoke
immediately begins to roll out of
Melisandre snows and mouth the red ruby
on her neck glow so bright that it
actually bursts into a red liquid that
begins to run down her chest onto the
sword as Jon pulls the sword out of her
chest the liquid from the red ruby
continues to cover the blade until the
sword itself begins to glow turning it
into the red sword of heroes Melisandre
is lifeless body collapses to the ground
we can see the reflection of the sword
burning in Jon Snow's eyes everyone
begins to run into position as the
thousands of blue eyes continue to get
closer Daenerys has shown mounting jerk
on Jon Snow takes our lone claw then he
tosses it to séjour Mormont without
saying a word Jorah Jaime bran the Hound
arya ginjury beric Brienne and all of
the others have their weapons drone we
can hear several wolves howl in the
distance
this gets Ari's attention she turns her
head to see where the noise was coming
from Jon Snow runs over to mal ragel
with the burning red sword still in hand
this is when the night King won't break
through the clouds flying faster than
anyone has ever seen a dragon fly before
Ariane swoops over the golden company in
torches hundreds of men in a single
strike John and Daenerys immediately
take to the sky
John signals for Daenerys to take out
his army while John heads after the
night King the night sky begins to light
up with bright colors of blue orange and
red the battlefield is on fire hundreds
and maybe even thousands are dying with
each pass of the dragons there are
nearly two dozen White Walkers leading
the army of the Dead half of them are
armed with ice Spears as are two of the
giants Jorah Jamie Barrack the hound Ori
again jury in Brienne all head for the
White Walkers
there will be an epic battle where seven
main characters fight roughly one dozen
White Walkers at the same time Geng jury
delivers the first devastating blow as
he smashes one of the White Walkers
right in the face with his dragonglass
Warhammer Arya Stark jams her dagger
into the side of the neck of another
white Walker Jorah Mormont kills one of
the White Walkers as he rescues Brienne
who is still recovering from a leg
injury she suffered in the first attack
Jaime Lannister is disarmed by one of
the White Walkers his sword falls to the
ground but Sir Bronn of the Blackwater
is there to pick it up and finish off
the white Walker for Jaime bran smiles
then he tosses the sword back he says if
you drop the bloody thing again
I'm keeping it every time we see a white
Walker died thousands of whites died
with it the commander of the golden
company is seen trying to load up one of
the ballistas he brought with him from
King's Landing he grabs a long shard of
dragonglass and fires it at one of the
Giants and the army of the Dead it hits
the Giant right in the chest killing it
immediately he loads up another shot
then takes aim at Vissarion but the
dragon is moving too fast to get a clear
shot another one of the White Walkers is
preparing to throw his ice spear at
Daenerys and Rogin but Jorah Mormont
charges at him causing the ice spear to
fall to the ground
unfortunately the white Walker is able
to overpower Jorah Mormont the white
Walker rips long claw from his hands
then turns the sword on Jorah shoving it
deep into his chest Jaime Lannister runs
up from behind in sticks what as well
and - the White Walkers back killing him
instantly but it's too late
Jorah Mormont is dead beric Dondarrion
sacrifices himself to save the Hound
from getting killed
another one of the White Walkers almost
half of the army of the Dead is gone now
that most of the White Walkers have been
defeated but the night King is still
winning the battle the whole encampment
is now getting swarmed by the whites
Daenerys kills the last remaining giant
as well as hundreds of more White's as
she attempts to push them back everyone
begins to fall back to the river John
finally catches up to the knight king
Ragle shoots his Flame adversary on but
it doesn't seem to have any effect on
the undead dragon with all the chaos
happening around them no one notices
another white Walker getting ready to
throw his ice spear this time he goes
for Jon Snow and ragle the ice spear
cuts right through a Gauls wing causing
the dragon to spiral out of control the
injury forces reg all to the ground
John Snow will now have to continue his
fight on foot with the glowing red sword
still in his hand
this is when everyone realizes they have
to kill Viserion otherwise they don't
stand a chance
Daenerys is not going to be able to kill
all the whites and fight off the night
king at the same time everyone begins to
fall back even further to where the
ballista is located now several
different characters are taking turns
trying to take miss Ariane out of the
sky bran is able to land a shot on
Viserion but the dragon glass actually
bounces off the dragon he fires again
and again and again but the dragon glass
either bounces off the dragon or
explodes on impact
finally can Vera whisper something to
bran we will then begin to see several
soldiers from the fiery hand form a
circle around bran
they will guard him as he tries
something that has never been done
before
brains eyes roll back in his head and
when this happens Vissarion almost
immediately lets out a thunderous scream
as bran enters his mind bryan has now
taken control of his ariane but we will
see blood start to run from brains nose
as the night king tries to force bran
out of the dragon brian will begin to go
into a seizure very similar to the ones
we saw Jojen have many seasons ago after
several tense moments Vasari Owen will
begin to fall from the sky the dragon
will slam into the ground
throwing the knight King off his back
when the few remaining white walkers see
this they will set their sights for bran
once again our heroes will get into
another epic battle with the white
walkers unfortunately there aren't very
many men left to hold them off but now
the Viserion is out of the sky
Daenerys is able to roast a few thousand
White's that are left although very
injured Breanna Tarth is able to kill
one of the White Walkers with Oathkeeper
however another one of the White Walkers
decapitates Lord Varys with a blow so
devastating it sends his head flying
nearly 100 feet across the battlefield
then all of a sudden the white Walker
stopped in their tracks everyone's
focused shifts to the knight King as he
is seen pulling a curved ice sword off
his back
the knight king takes one last look at
Vasari oh and as the dragon closes his
eyes for good John notices Daenerys
coming back around on drug on he weighs
his red sword in the air signalling for
Daenerys to land behind him John sees
this as his opportunity to finally
challenge the knight King to 1vs1 combat
everyone on the battlefield is now in a
standstill with their eyes set on Jon
Snow and the knight King they never take
their eyes off each other as they walk
to the middle of the battlefield John
and the knight King continued walking
until they are about ten feet from one
another the knight King is holding his
ice sword and John is holding his
burning red sword of heroes they stand
here staring at each other silently for
what seems like several minutes this is
the exact imagery brain stark saw over
and over again in his visions Jon Snow
is the black silhouette standing
face-to-face with the night King with a
burning red sword in his hand
finally Jon Snow and the knight King
begin to move it's very slow at first as
they move in circles sizing each other
up neither one of them are ready to
commit to any particular move that could
possibly leave them exposed after a few
more moments of this John finally takes
a swing at the knight King said but he
misses by a mile it's obvious the knight
King is so much faster than the White
Walkers then the knight King takes a
swing at John causing John to lose his
footing but he quickly recovers when
John looks down he notices the ice sword
cut right through his fur and leather it
was much closer than he thought the
knight king swings again but john is not
fast enough to get out of the way this
time the ice sword cuts and burns into
John's arm causing him to hold the sword
with his other hand John grips the
handle as hard as he can then swings the
sword as fast as the snap of a whip the
knight King raises his ice sword to
block the shot but the burning sword
cuts right
through shattering the ice sword into a
thousand pieces john has confidence now
but tonight King takes several steps
back as one of the White Walkers
simultaneously throws him another weapon
the night King snaps the ice spear over
his knee now creating a weapon for each
hand the local on John's face lets us
know his confidence is already slipping
away but he takes a deep breath anyway
and rushes forward the fighting that
ensues over the next few minutes will be
very reminiscent of when Ned Stark
footsore Arthur Dayne at the Tower of
joy every time John rushes in the night
king will force him back every time the
night King rushes in John somehow holds
him off although some of the strikes
were not very clean the night King has
made contact many times when he sees
that John is struggling to stand and
catch his breath the night King moves in
for the kill the night King rushes in
one last time bring in both ends of the
ice spear high above his head but as he
brings them down John lunges forward
with his burning sword jamming it right
through the night King's armor deep into
his chest the night King explodes into a
thousand pieces of ice just like we saw
in season eight the rest of his army
falls with him we can see steam rising
off John's sword in water dripping from
it onto the ground everyone watching was
holding their breath during those last
few moments but they all finally let out
a sigh of relief the clouds in the sky
begin to open up the snow suddenly stops
swallowing the red glow on John's sword
begins to dim Daenerys moves her hand
over her stomach as she feels the baby
begin to kick John sees this and he
walks over to the Narus he embraces her
in front of everyone then he embraces
his family as daylight begins to appear
through the clouds everyone starts to
walk across the battlefield it's nothing
but death and destruction all around
them Sean's and Arya walk over to speak
with John they both ask him what they're
gonna do next John looks completely
exhausted at this point but before he
can answer
Daenerys says there is only one thing
left to do the episode ends as Daenerys
says we're gonna kill Cersei Lannister
and take back the Iron Throne
you
the final episode begins with us getting
a good look at just how devastating that
battle was there are thousands upon
thousands of dead bodies scattered
across the battlefield the exact
location where rhaegar targaryen 'he's
lifeless body once fell has now turned
into a river of blood Daenerys Targaryen
once had one of the greatest forces
Westeros has ever seen but after the
battle against the night King she now
has less than 1,000 men in her army the
men that survived do not appear as if
they can even March on to King's Landing
let alone fight in another battle before
they make any decisions they will hold a
ceremony for all of their fallen friends
very similar to the one we saw during
season eight during a very somber scene
they will burn the bodies of Jorah
Mormont
beric Dondarrion Varys Melisandre Ken
vara and many many others afterwards
Jonathan Aerys will go speak to the
commander of the golden company since he
currently has the most amount of
able-body soldiers left they begin to
devise a strategy about how they're
going to attack King's Landing
he tells Jonathan Ayers about all the
recent additions to the city's defenses
Daenerys is worried about attacking the
city with her dragons now that she knows
there are dozens of ballista set up
around the city gates aiming directly at
the sky they also know they no longer
have the numbers to hit the capital
head-on this is when the Lannister
brothers become very useful they tell
John and Daenerys if they can get them
close enough to the red key without
getting spotted they can get them inside
the castle they are very familiar with
all the city's secret tunnels this gets
Arya Starks attention she too knows
about a secret way to get in and out of
the red key she tells them about the
time that she was chasing a cat through
the dungeons of the Red Keep and how
that secret passageway led out to a
storm drain that empty right into the
Blackwater Bay before they leave they
gather up some of their best fighters to
take with them on the back of the
Dragons they want to enter the city
right away
although the remaining soldiers will
have to march there by foot this scene
will lend as we see a few dozen
characters take to the sky on the back
of Drogo and Rey go as John is flying
regal he looks back at the trident one
last time we get our final glimpse of
the battlefield
and the massive fires that are burning
all of the Fallen men and woman who help
save the realm from what would have
likely been the
stinking of human existence in the
following scene sir see you're on the
mountain and Qyburn are discussing their
own plans in case they come under attack
anytime soon Circe tells Qyburn if it
looks like this city is about to fall
make sure all the candles and torches
are laid near the wildfire Cersei has no
intentions of surrendering or fleeing
King's Landing Circe's made one thing
very clear if the walls are breached
she will blow up the entire city or die
trying' the Mad King already had
wildfire stashed all over the city but
Cersei made sure Qyburn placed the
majority of it right under the red key
there are hundreds of pots directly
underneath the Great Hall where the Iron
Throne is located after they discussed
their strategy Cersei asked I burn leave
the room she wants to have a word with
your own alone Cersei closes the door
behind her cutting us off from hearing
what she had to say - you're on we then
follow Qyburn back outside we can see
that the capital is very alive this
evening there are Lannister soldiers and
Men of the city watch walking along the
top of the castle walls
there are several men guarding each gate
as well as several men standing next to
the ballistas King's Landing is ready
for battle the scene ends as Qyburn
receives a note from one of his little
birds his eyes go very wide as he reads
the contents of the letter he
immediately heads back for Circe's
chambers we go back to John and Daenerys
flying on the Dragons we're able to see
the glow at King's Landing far off into
the distance
John signals for them to land the
dragons near the water there's still
several miles outside of the city but
they don't want to take the dragons too
close just yet the Sun is almost all the
way down by the time they get everyone
off the Dragons they have decided to
send an aria and Jaime first but they
want to wait until they can hide under
the cover of darkness although they
still do not completely trust Jaime
Lannister
they know he is very familiar with the
inner workings of the red key and if he
did somehow get spotted by the guards he
might be able to convince them that he's
returning to fight for Cersei arya was
chosen not only because she knows her
way around the castle but also because
of her faceless men training all of that
training makes her a perfect candidate
for a mission like this one they've
decided to enter through the storm drain
Arya found when she was chasing the cat
through the dungeons
since the drain emptied into the
Blackwater Bay they will be able to get
there via boat which they hope to find
in the next village along the way
thankfully theon greyjoy was able to
make off with most of your own Greyjoy's
fleet so the Blackwater Bay should be
very quiet tonight their plan is to find
a small fishing boat in the next village
then Ari and Jamie will slowly paddle
the boat along the shore of King's
Landing until they reach the storm drain
right below the red key once they enter
the drain they will make their way into
the dungeons inside the red key right
where the dragon skulls are located when
they get inside they're gonna split up
Jaime will immediately look for Circe
and Euron while Aria kills the first
Lannister guard she comes across inside
the castle she will then wear the
Lannister guards face and uniform which
will allow her to move freely throughout
the city then she can go to one of the
back gates kill all the guards then
leave it open for everyone else to enter
the city after that Arya will walk along
the top of the castle walls then wave
one of the torches to give the signal
that the gate is open then begin killing
as many men that are Manning the
ballistas as possible once all of the
others get inside the city they will
first head to the ballistas to destroy
them then they will give another signal
which is when Jon and Daenerys will know
that it's time to attack with the
dragons now that everyone knows the plan
Arya and Jaime began walking down to the
shoreline in search for a small boat
Jaime has first stopped by Bronn who
hands him the small dagger that's always
kept tucked behind his back he tells
Jaime you will be in close quarters
while inside the castle besides it will
be much easier for you to use that than
the sword on your hip after walking for
about a mile Arya and Jaime do come
across a boat it's secured to the dock
by some old rusted chain arias Valyrian
steel dagger cuts right through it like
butter they quietly carry the boat down
to the water then slowly make their way
to Blackwater Bay
it takes them about another hour before
they land on the shore right behind the
red key they don't waste any time
pulling the boat onto the rocks then
dragging it into the storm train with
them so no one happens to see it Arya
hasn't been inside this drain for many
years it takes them quite some time to
find a way around the sewer system but
they do finally find their way into the
dungeons below the Great Hall of the red
key this is where Jaime and re-add the
separate ways before they do arya grabs
Jaime by the arm before he heads in the
opposite direction
her eyes are burning a hole right
through him arya says if you betray my
family
again it will be your face that I'm
wearing when I kill your sister Jamie
looks scared he gives her a nod as in he
believes she will do it it's not long
before Aria slips back outside the red
key only this time she's walking through
the city streets
it only takes her a few moments before
she comes across the first Lannister
guard she executes him immediately
then dawns his face and uniform she
walks past several other guards who
don't even give her a second look this
might actually work before the guards
notice anyone is there Arya begins
cutting their throats one by one she
unlocks the gate then heads for the top
of the wall to give the others the
signal The Hound and Brienne are waiting
for the signal they see Arya waving the
torch in the air now they know it's time
to enter the city we go back to Arya who
is now beginning to attack the men
guarding each ballista there are roughly
a dozen of them spaced out on this side
of the wall so she has to take her time
to avoid getting detected one of the
Lannister soldiers eventually spots a
dead body laying next to a ballista he
gives his own signal to sound the alarm
which alerts the entire city
this forces John and Daenerys to react
before all of the blisters are even
taken out they climb on the Dragons and
head right for the red key John and
Danny want to burn all the ballistas
first then blow out a section of the
wall to allow the rest of their men
inside they both fly right over top of
the Red Keep and begin to torch the wall
that protects the inner city Jaime
Lannister can hear the chaos erupted
then outside therefore he knows he
doesn't have much time left some of the
Lannister soldiers begin firing the
ballistas at the dragons but it's not
easy hitting a moving target at night
Arya who is still disguised as a guard
kills them to Jon and Daenerys finally
break through the wall with their
dragons John lands regel so he can help
the others climb over the rubble to get
inside the city Cersei and Euron run
outside one to the balcony to watch from
above Cersei is very surprised when she
sees Daenerys still has two dragons
alive she was hoping the army the dead
would have killed her others for her out
of an act of desperation
Cersei orders the mountain to go outside
of the red keep to fight he's not to
allow anyone inside then Cersei signals
for Qyburn to go down and like the
Wildfire underneath the Great Hall
she knows the Capitol will not stand for
much longer she's not about to watch her
city fall by the hands of some foreign
horror and bastard from the
north Euron leaves with Qyburn help see
it through leaving Searcy all alone in
her chambers but in reality
Euron has plans of his own he wants to
escape from the city before it falls
leaving Searcy to her own demise Jaime
Lannister watches as the mountain walks
down the stairs he's not sure what he's
doing but he hides until he walks
through the room Jaime then begins to
climb the stairs heading for Circe's
chambers right as Jaime is about to come
around the corner
he can hear Kai Bart and Euron talking
in low voices he grabs the dagger bran
gave him then crouches down and waits
for them to turn the corner The Hound
immediately spots his brother as he
walks out the double doors the mountain
begins walking along the top of the wall
lighting the stashes wildfire and each
post The Hound finds his way to the top
of the wall and cuts his brother off
before he can light the next ash a
wildfire it's an intense stare down for
a few moments but the Hound eventually
challenges his brother to 1vs1 combat
the mountain sets the torch down and the
fighting begins an epic sword fight will
ensue but the Hound is still no match
for his bigger and stronger brother
after several minutes of fighting they
both end up losing their swords a brutal
fistfight begins lasting for another
several minutes the Hound will
eventually smash upon a wildfire over
his brothers helmet completely covering
him in the highly flammable substance as
the mountain is trying to recover the
Hound grabs one of the torches from the
wall and tosses it right on his brother
burning him alive inside of his heavy
armor this scene then cuts to Jaime who
lunges out from around the corner
Jaime shoves his dagger deep into Kai
burns throat all the way down to the
handle this catches your own off-guard
but what Jaime only have in one hand
he's still easily overpowered and taken
to the ground an intense struggle will
last for several minutes between the two
until Jaime knocks out some of Euron's
teeth with his golden hand
Joran chokes on his own blood Jaime
scrambles and takes the dagger out of
Kai burns throat then swings it around
and drives it right into Euron's chest
Jaime stands back up when he sees you're
on close his eyes he leaves the dagger
in his chest
then he fixes himself and heads for
Circe's chambers Jaime enters the room
closes the door then he locks it behind
him Cersei can all believe that Jaime's
here
she was sure that he would have died in
the north he was the last man she was
expecting to see Searcy immediately
notices the blood on Jamie's hand she
begins to cry out to him saying how much
she loves him and how glad she is to
have him here then she begins to touch
her stomach until Jamie how she still
has his child inside of her Jamie
doesn't say anything at first he allows
Cersei to embrace him as his own eyes
are filling up with water
he looks Cersei in the eyes and tells
her that he loves her he then gives her
a kiss on the forehead as Cersei begins
to cry
Cersei says I always knew you would come
back and save me she leans in to give
him a kiss on the lips but right before
their lips are about to touch Cersei
begins gasping for air Jaime has both
hands on a throat his left hand is
squeezing as tight as he possibly can
while he pushes down to apply pressure
with his golden hand Circe's legs begin
to give out but Jaime continues
squeezing as he moves down to the floor
with her tears start to roll down his
cheek knowing Cersei only has a few
moments left
she tries gasping for breath one more
time before her body stops moving her
bloodshot eyes are fixed on Jamie still
Jaime gently sets down her head then he
moves his hand over her eyes the scene
will fade to black as Circe's eyes
closed one last time the rains of
castamere begin to play back outside
there are fires all over the city Jon
and Daenerys are methodically burning
the tops of the walls surrounding the
red key killing any and every Lannister
soldier who dared to remain outside the
remaining men of the city watch begin to
lay down their weapons it's obvious this
battle cannot be won Cersei City has
fallen before her wildfire could be
ignited once again
Jaime Lannister has saved King's Landing
from total destruction Jon and Daenerys
land their dragons just outside of the
red key The Hound Brienne Arya and
Tyrion Lannister are there to meet them
we see one of the Lannister banners is
on fire as it falls to the ground
representing the end of house Lannisters
rain in the Seven Kingdoms Jonathan
Ayers begin to climb the steps together
to the red key as more and more sunlight
begins to appear through the clouds
everyone can see just how much
destruction has been caused to the
capital King's Landing looks like a
smoking ruins almost everything is
burned
from the dragon fire some of these fires
can still be seen burning throughout the
city nearly all of the Lannister
soldiers are dead and those who did
survive only did because they chose to
lay down their arms in the face of the
Dragons the survivors are looking around
the city in disbelief right is John and
Daenerys reached the front doors of the
red key we go back inside sir she's
chambers to see Jaime Lannister he is
still clutching Circe's lifeless body in
his arms he continues to hold her and
look at her for a few more moments Jaime
kisses Cersei one last time on the
forehead then he carries her body over
to the bed Jimmy wipes the tears off his
cheek and out of his eyes before he
exits the room when he does exit the
room he glances over at Kye burns dead
body laying on the floor in a pool of
blood as he walks around the corner he
is then completely shocked by what he
sees next there is more blood on the
floor but you're on Greyjoy is gone he
can see some of Euron's teeth laying
there from when he knocked them out and
he can even see the dagger on the ground
Jaime has killed enough men to know that
the injury to his chest should have been
fatal someone either took his body for
some reason or urine is still alive and
possibly even escaped the city by now
back outside we followed the Hound as he
walks up the steps to the top of the
wall he walks over to where he last left
his brother some of the Wildfire is
still burning around his body the Hound
has to cover his nose because of the
stench of the burnt flesh most of the
mountains armor has melted into the
stone wall there's almost nothing left
of the enormous man that was once known
as the mountain that rides next we see
Jon and Daenerys enter the Great Hall
Jon stays by the door as Daenerys walks
over to the Iron Throne Daenerys is
finally looking at the symbol of power
she so desperately tried to win back and
her family's name now the Iron Throne
resides in a city that is in complete
and utter ruins Danny looks disgusted
she walks all the way up to the Iron
Throne to get a closer look but it's not
long before she turns back around and
head for the doors she's lost all
interest in actually sitting on the Iron
Throne Daenerys and John exit the room
to head back outside John wants to know
what the Narus will do about the Iron
Throne
Daenerys says I want it burned melt down
the chair King's Landing will no longer
be the capitol of Westeros I said I
wanted to break the wheel well that's
exactly what I'm
gonna do we have all made too many
sacrifices for us to continue repeating
this same vicious cycle over and over
again we will no longer have one king or
queen ruling the Seven Kingdoms from
that iron throne
John has a few men carrying some pots of
wildfire into the throne room after
covering the throne in the flammable
substance
Daenerys grabs a torch from the wall
then tosses it onto the iron throne it
ignites immediately and doesn't take
long before the chair begins to melt
like a candle as it melts down and turns
into a puddle of liquid iron the screen
fades to black as if the episode is
ending several months will have went by
before we enter our next scene
the sun is shining and all of the land
is beginning to look lush again we're
back in Winterfell for the first time
since the night King attacked the Starks
home the walls have mostly crumbled to
the ground the gods what is Bart black
with the massive weirwood tree laying on
its side Jon Daenerys Songza Arya bran
ginjury Brienne Tyrion Jaime and a few
others walking to the courtyard songs
immediately says we need to find some
builders and get them to Winterfell as
soon as we can we can't leave our home
looking like this
Jon nods his head in agreement but
suddenly everyone stops in their tracks
when they hear the sound of wolves
howling in the distance
Arya's eyes go wide she isn't sure if
she actually heard the sound or if it
was in her head everyone hears it again
but this time it's much closer than
before Arya looks at Jon then Jon points
to the main gate there is a massive pack
of wolves running down the hill heading
their way
arya has a big smile come across her
face there's no mistake in who is
leading that pack Nymeria has returned
to Winterfell as well Arya takes off
running to the main gate to greet her
John's also smiling but this makes him
think a ghost he hasn't seen him since
the castle came under attack
Jon doesn't know if ghost made it out
alive or not everyone begins to go
inside together in the main dining hall
for a meeting Daenerys Targaryen is
visibly pregnant she's actually ready to
give birth any day now in the main hall
everyone gets a chance to voice their
opinion about how the Seven Kingdoms
should be rein in the future they all
take votes and decide that each Kingdom
should be independent with its own
Council to decide how
territory will be ran there will no
longer be one person deciding what's
best for everyone as of right now most
of the Seven Kingdoms are in shambles
since Westeros has been at war with each
other for so long they take another vote
and decide that John and Daenerys should
oversee everything together until
Westeros is stabilized again kingdoms
and castles need to be rebuilt so many
things will need to be done in order for
Westeros to be restored to its former
glory
and even beyond everyone decides that
the Nights Watch will be abolished
immediately the night's king and his
army are gone the wildlings are nearly
gone and those who are still alive have
been led into the North to live out the
remainder of their lives since there are
no more threats beyond the wall they
decide there will no longer be a use for
the Nights Watch they even decide that
the wall itself should be taken down
they want the north to be wide open
again
John and Danny both agree to this they
also decide that each major family will
get to keep their ancestral homes
Gendry is legitimized in offered storms
end Jaime and Tyrion are both allowed to
take up residence at Casterly Rock
however they all decide to stay in
Winterfell until the Starks Castle is
restored they all want to help see the
Seven Kingdoms get rebuilt before they
go home
Jon informs his family that he's not
gonna be staying in Winterfell after
it's rebuilt he will be heading south to
Dragonstone with Daenerys so they can
raise their child together
John also says he wants to marry Dany
before she gives birth he will not allow
his child to become a bastard like he
thought he was for so many years Jon
hopes that Sansa Arya and bran will stay
in Winterfell together brain says he
can't do that he says I must go to the
gods I soon I'm not fit to spend the
rest of my life in some castle I have to
be what the we're woods Jon doesn't
fully understand but he doesn't say
anything either brain is old enough to
make his own decisions anyway Jon and
Daenerys decide to Wed in the godswood
within a few days even though it has
been destroyed
Daenerys says she wouldn't mind having a
traditional northern wedding
afterwards Jon heads down into the
crypts of Winterfell it's one of the
only places that was left undisturbed by
the battle this will be the first time
Jon looks upon Lee on a statue knowing
she's his mother this will be a very
emotional moment for him not only
because he finally knows who his mother
is but also because of what Ned Stark
did for him
now he knows Ned tarnished his own honor
in order to keep him safe
as John is looking at both of their
statues he hears something moving around
in the darkness this causes him to draw
his sword and take a few steps back
after staring into the darkness for
several moments John notices two red
eyes glowing in the distance before he
can react the glowing red eyes move
forward and leap out of the darkness at
John he's knocked down to the ground and
showered with kisses from his beloved
direwolf ghost has been hiding down here
the entire time after the castle was
abandoned ghost did return home and
stayed in the crypts until someone came
back now this becomes an even bigger
emotional moment for John he's so happy
to see that ghost is still alive the
scene ends as we get a shot of John
hugging ghosts in front of his mother
statue next we will see a conversation
between Songza Brienne and Jaime
Lannister this is where Songza will
relieve Brienne of her duties she tells
Brienne she is free to go home if she
would like Brienne says if Jaime is
staying here to help rebuild Winterfell
then I will stay and help as well
Brienne then says Jaime gave me this
sword to help keep me safe while I went
looking for you then to keep you safe
thereafter this was your father's sword
I don't feel right holding on to it any
longer
it belongs with House Stark Jamie pulls
out his sword and says you should take
this too both of these swords were made
from your father's I'm no longer a
competent swordsman anyway Brienne is
right they belong with House Stark
sansei accepts but tells them as long as
you're gonna be here help and restore
our home hold on to them until you're
done bran Stark is sitting out in the
courtyard waiting for his family to see
him off he looks much thinner than he
used to
he appears the beginning SiC Jon Arya
and songs that come outside to see bran
one last time he tells them he's on his
way to the gods eye he says he doesn't
feel very well but he should be fine
when he's back with the weirwood trees
Jon has gathered a few dozen men to help
escort bran down the Kings Road this is
when Arya interrupts and informs
everyone that she will be leaving to Jon
and sanso seemed very surprised by the
news Jon wants to know where she's
heading Arya says I have to go back to
Braavos
Sansa seems confused she says Braavos
why arias says I have some unfinished
business John says well when are you
leaving
Aria says I'm leaving now I will stay
with bran until he gets to the gods eye
but then I'm sailing across the sea this
will be a very emotional scene as
everyone says their goodbyes sandor
clegane is seen waiting by the main gate
Aria gives him a nod as she climbs onto
her horse it appears as if Sandor is
traveling with her too but we're not
sure why Theon and Yara both agreed to
stay and help but they had decided they
are going back to the Iron Islands
afterwards
ever since Jamie said Euron's body was
missing from the red keep they fear that
Euron could show up again and try to
start some kind of an uprising
Euron was badly wounded and he no longer
has the iron fleet but he's still a very
dangerous man Sam and Gilly are heading
back to Hornell Sam tells John him and
Kelley will be getting married he wants
little Sam to have his last name John
and Danny both say that Sam and Gilly
can return home whenever they'd like but
Sam volunteers to stay and help the
north took the most amount of damage
since it was directly in the night Kings
path they could use all the help they
can get in one of the very last scenes
Daenerys goes into labor Sam and Gilly
both assist her during the process
Daenerys gives birth to a set of twins a
boy and a girl the boy has dark hair
just like his father and the girl has
silvery blond hair just like her mother
they will both be given that Targaryen
last name Jon and Daenerys tell songs
that they will believe in once she makes
a full recovery they will be living at
Dragonstone together as a family the
last time we see Jon and Daenerys are
down in the crypts of Winterfell they
are holding their children as they're
looking at Ned and Lyanna statues
telling them about their family in the
final scene we will see different
locations around Westeros the last
hearth the karhold
and Winterfell are shown being rebuilt
in the north we will also see King's
Landing getting rebuilt we will see
farmers attending to their crops we will
see livestock and fishing villages
booming again Westeros seems to be on
track to being better than ever
but finally we will see a large weirwood
tree surrounded by water this will be
the largest weirwood tree we have ever
seen the features on the face that's
carved into
the tree looked very similar to brands
underneath the tree is a cave just like
the three-eyed Ravens but much larger we
will follow a child of the forest deep
into the cave where we will see brain
stark entangled into a weirwood throne
his eyes are rolled back in his head
after looking at him for a few moments
we will then follow a raven whose eyes
are solid white we will know brain stark
is inside of the bird as he takes it far
into the north past the wall deep into
the heart of winter he flies the Raven
into the lands of always winter we see
the ice altar where the night king
turned one a crest her son's into a
white Walker only this time it looks
much different now there are symbols
carved into the ice the same symbols we
have seen the White Walkers leave time
and time again right as bran lanes the
Raven onto the ice altar the ice beneath
it begins to crack this forces brand out
of the Raven and back into his own mind
bran is gasping for breath he looks at
the child of the forest with complete
shock he won't have to say a word
because we will already know what this
implies there are white Walker still
sleeping under the ice I want to thank
everyone for watching this is basically
how I would have ended this series now I
may have done things a little
differently if I had more time to write
but I still feel like this would have
been a much better ending let me know
what you think down below I really
appreciate all your support I hope you
come back for the next video have a
great day bye
[Music]
[Music]
you